- I'll give you a quick run-through
of Dhar Mann video right now.
Hi, I am cheating wife.
(moody music)
Hi, I am husband with failing business.
Damn, you're so gross.
I'm going to cheat on you, she cheats.
(coins clanking)
My business is now succeeding.
Cheating wife wants to come
back and sleep with him again,
but he's like, no, no, I'm successful now.
Moral of the story, don't
cheat on your husband.
(laughing)
(bones cracking)
- And, then everyone clapped.
(applause)
- [Connor] Yeah.
(chill ambience music)
Welcome to Trash Tastes Podcast.
This is the most recent episode
you'll ever experience
on Trash Taste, I think.
- Yeah. This is the first time, I think
since we started that we used
the entirety of our backlog.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- So we can talk about topics
that happens literally just last week
as this is airing right now.
- Whoa!
- Which, I actually do want to, but-
- Timely!
- But, I did see a thing.
They were like, please,
can you start talking
about more recent topics?
It's so annoying hearing
it like four weeks later.
I don't know.
I like the fact that we get
to like sit on it a little bit
and we get to talk about it.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And, it comes out later.
- Yeah, 'cause so much happens
or so much changes, right.
Especially if it just happened.
Like you know, something might happen
where it completely changes
our opinions or situations.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- And then we just look like idiots.
It's just poorly, aged videos, right?
- Yeah. I mean, I think it
just works well for us as well,
because it just proves that, you know,
we don't have to talk about
current topics to get people,
to watch us hopefully.
- By the way do you want
to introduce ourselves?
(laughing)
- What do you mean?
We're here with the boys.
- I don't think I did.
- Hello we're the boys.
- We really just like went right into it.
- We're the boys, that's it.
- Hello, this is like
episode two of season two.
You know who we are.
You know who we are, obviously.
(laughing)
- I think episode 54 was
like five weeks ahead.
And then the episode after that was just
one week ahead.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- So it's like, it's interesting,
but I do like the fact that, I mean,
the way we record it, is cause that's
how we like to do it,
right? - [Garnt] Yeah.
- We like to have the backlog
so that we always give you
an episode weekly and we
don't really give a shit
about trending topics, most of the time.
- [Joey] No. No.
- I think we want to just talk anyway.
- Most trending topics just don't mean
anything to us really.
- Yeah, and even then really,
I feel like, you know,
we don't really go that deeply into it.
You know, we're not doing
a two hour deep dive
on the newest scandal.
- [Joey] I mean how-
- We just kind of mention
it in passing like,
oh, that was a shitty thing.
- [Joey] Right.
- Which is what I will
be talking about today.
- I mean how can you when
it literally just happened
and you have so little
information to work off, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, and also I feel like
we're not, like a drama channel.
- [Garnt] No.
- If you want the hot
scoops, the hot takes,
it's not from us.
- [Garnt] No.
- [Joey] No.
- We have hot takes about
fucking food and all other shit.
like non-timely topics.
(laughing)
- But speaking of hot topics,
there is one that came up
recently that I thought was
just so incredibly fucking stupid
that I do want to talk about it.
- [Garnt] Go on. Yeah.
- I tweeted about it yesterday, as well.
- [Joey] Oh!
- It was the crypto,
the crypto scam, but the FaZe Clan.
- Yeah, I tweeted about
that yesterday as well.
- I'm not being funny.
If you believe in any financial advice
from someone from the FaZe Clan,
- FaZe Clan!
(laughing)
- You have to start
questioning what's going on.
But I know most of this kids are,
well, I don't think most of them are young
because how the fuck do
they have crypto wallets?
I'm 25 and I barely can
get a crypto wallet.
- Very, very, very naive parents.
- I am all out the loop.
Can you explain to me what I missed?
- Ah that's right, Garnt, of course.
So FaZe Clan, which if you don't know,
are an absolutely massive
organization on YouTube.
- [Garnt] Yes.
- They have members that I can not
distinguish to save my life.
They all sound and feel
very familiar in my head.
- There's also like 70
of them or something.
- [Connor] Yeah. There's like-
- There's a shitload of them.
- Yeah. I don't know how many there is,
there's about like,
I think there's less than 10 of them.
They're all massive.
- No, there's more than 10.
- Is there?
- There has to be.
- I just know that they are gamers.
- They're gamers, so ya
they're mainly gamers.
They mainly do, you know,
very click-bait videos.
A lot of them to cover very hot games.
So like, when it's Fortnite,
they're Fortnite, you know,
and then they kind of pick
up the biggest creators.
Most of them have over
like 5 million subs.
- [Garnt] Yeah. Yeah.
- So most of them have
over 10 million subs.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And a few of them have recently started,
you know, advertising cryptocurrencies.
- Oh, I like where this is going!
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It seems to have been a concerning topic
with influencers in general recently
where they've been-
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- You know, I don't mind you talking
about your crypto investments and whatnot.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- But, there's a difference between that
and being like, "Hey, invest in whatever."
So there was the big scandal this time,
was that, there was a coin called
like Save the Kids-
- [Joey] Yeah. Yeah.
- [Garnt] Right.
- Foundation.
It's literally called like,
this is like a parody.
Like, this is what, like a parody movie,
would call this scam.
- [Joey] Yeah.
Save the Kids.
You know what I mean?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And it had like all of them,
it had this like flashy promotional video
where all of them were like,
"I'm here to save the kids,"
like all the FaZe Clan members were like,
"I'm holding to save the kids."
And so they advertise this coin
that they also like had someone
who helped them develop it.
So they were in from the start developing
this coin, making it.
- [Joey] Yeah.
[Garnt] Right.
- So they had all the coin
before even went live.
And if you don't know
how cryptocurrency works,
I'm not gonna explain it
because, I don't know.
- There's videos on YouTube.
- Frankly I don't know.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- All I know is that they had the money
before they had access to this marketplace
before anyone did,
they already had all the money.
They promoted the fuck out of it.
I mean, it's typically called
a pump and dump, right.
So you promote the shit out of it.
The value goes up.
- And then you sell off your-
- And then, they sold all
of their coin immediately.
So when this coin went up in value
and it went immediately to shit.
- [Joey] Yeah.
There's actually graphs
of it that you can see
where it's like, day one,
it's like up here and then it just goes.
(imitates falling rocket)
- Yeah so I think it started
off like one, one penny,
it was worth.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- These coins. And then it was, well,
I think now it's worth less
than a hundredth of a penny.
- I think it's like a
thousandth of of a penny.
It's even less than that.
- [Connor] Yeah, it's ridiculous.
- Feels like that should be illegal.
- I think it might be.
- Well, if you did this stuff like this
in the stock market,
it would be very illegal.
- Yeah. That's what I'm saying, right!
- It's like some Wolf of
Wall Street shit, right?
- And that's the...
Because I feel like I'm
just the guy watching
the shit show that is crypto.
I don't really give a
about getting into crypto,
but I love keeping up with it
and love seeing the drama.
And they're always just
at each other's throat
on whether they want regulation or not.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And so that's the debate of do,
should it be regulated to stop shit
like this from happening?
But even then I think the,
if the FEC, or I think that's what it is,
wanted to investigate, I
think they could arrest them.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And, someone actually
found their wallets.
- [Garnt] Right.
- Their crypto wallets, which is unique
to the person who buys or sells a crypto.
You can only have one.
- [Garnt] Yeah. It's-
- Or you can have more than one wallet,
but it's a unique thing
that everyone can see
cause crypto is public.
And so people managed to
find the FaZe Clan's wallets,
- [Garnt] Right.
- And saw that at least one
of them, a bunch of them,
a bunch of them all sold immediately,
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Which shows that they kind
of had some malicious intent.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And one of them had done like
four of these schemes
and sold immediately every single time.
(snickering)
And bear in mind, if
this was for, you know,
these people have like 10 million subs.
So their income is probably
already over, you know,
seven figures a year.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Right?
And so they're doing these,
I mean, they're just scams.
That's blatantly what they are, right?
- I mean, these, these, these are just-
- Call it what it is.
It's a fucking scam.
- It is a scam.
- They're running these scams that could
easily put them in jail.
And some of them only made like 50 grand.
And don't get me wrong 50
grand is a lot of money.
It's a lot of money.
- But in retrospect of how much
they're already probably making.
- Bro if they did a raid
fucking Shadow Legends,
they'd get 100K, are you kidding me?
(laughing)
Like,
why are they risking their life for 50K?
- That's not a lot in like,
in the grand scheme of things,
for the amount that they're making
and for what they're
putting on the line as well?
That's like going into tax evasion
to like save a tenner
or something like that.
(Laughing)
Like, what are the,
what the fuck are they doing?
- At least, at least when you rob people,
you can wear a ski mask.
- [Garnt] Yeah, right?
- This is like, they're
fucking promoting it publicly.
And then their fucking wallets are public.
- I thought they were
like making millions.
And that's what it sounds.
That's what it sounded like.
- It's sounded so elaborate.
And so like crazy that I was like,
these guys must be getting
millions from this.
No, they made like 60K.
And it's like, what you
guys are so fucking dumb.
This is the dumbest thing I've seen.
Like at least with the fucking,
the whole Tmartn CSGO gambling thing-
- Yeah, yeah, Yeah. That's
what they remind me of.
- At least he was
probably making millions.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah. Easily.
- If you're gonna like risk your life,
at least, that's what pissed
me off the most about this.
I'm like, you guys are so fucking dumb.
I couldn't believe this.
Like, when I saw it.
- Just upload a couple of vlogs,
just add a shitload of minerals,
I mean, you'd probably
make the same amount.
- Yeah. Yeah. It's just, I, you know,
and I've watched channels
that are dedicated
to finding these like crypto scams
and there's so many YouTubers doing this.
It's so appalling.
It's so sad.
- It's pretty fucked.
Like the more like I've
seen people reacting to it,
I've just never looked into
what was going on myself.
It just seems like, yeah,
very much like the CSO skim scam, right?
Or whatever.
I forget what that scam was called.
- Kind of like that,
but at least at least gambling, you know,
there's something there.
You just lose with this.
then you just getting scammed.
- At least you get skins.
(laughing)
- Yeah this is like a
butterfly knife. I don't know.
- You don't get anything
with this crypto shit.
Yeah. I don't know, man.
It's like, and there was a bunch
of other YouTubers were
doing it too, right?
- It's quite a lot. Quite a lot.
- Like, I think like, I mean,
Rice Scum, I think was involved
in the FaZe thing as well.
- For fuck's sake!
- Well Rice Scum is in FaZe Clan.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Oh my god.
- He was in FaZe Clan.
So he was part of the campaign as well,
because I saw-
- And then Sam Pepper is apparently,
do you remember Sam Pepper?
(Joey laughs and claps)
So Sam Pepper is a well known,
very well known prank channel.
And he was canceled a while back.
Of course he is known.
He's very popular right now,
because he's doing crypto scams.
- Are we just going through
like the fucking top 10 list
of YouTuber scumbags that were-
- Yeah.
- [Connor] Literally, literally.
- Because, that's what
it sounds like, right?
- Pick a YouTube scumbag,
they're doing this cyrpto bullshit.
- They're literally doing crypto bullshit.
- Yeah.
- Logan Paul was doing it as well, right?
- Logan Paul, yeah!
- Oh my God.
- Logan Paul was pushing this shit.
- Of course he was!
- I've never, been one for like,
you should lose your platform for stuff.
But, I genuinely think if
you're doing this shit,
you shouldn't be allowed on YouTube.
- Well yeah of course.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- How YouTube let's like
people who do this shit,
like still upload.
- [Joey] Right.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And like, cause it's, you know,
we already have a bad
enough rep as YouTubers.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- We already have like one of
the worst reps of any reps.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- The last thing we need
is every single person over
10 million subs fucking
shilling garbage crypto
that is blatantly a scam. You know?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And it's so shitty as well, right.
Because like internet
personalities are like built
on like a trust, right?
Of like, I love this content creator.
- Who is trusting these guys?
I don't understand.
- I love these people.
- Yeah.
- And, what I want to know is
how they're getting away with this shit.
How?
- There's no regulation on it,.
- Yeah.
- You know?
- You know, as much as you know,
a lot of people don't want
websites to get involved.
Rightfully so, because
YouTube and Twitter,
where they normally try and enforce shit,
it's a fucking mess.
- [Joey] Mm-hmm (affirmative). Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- So it's kind of this thing of like,
well maybe there should be exceptions,
when they're notably being scumbags.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. I mean, I don't even know is if
what they're doing is illegal,
but I assume if it is illegal,
then that is like a genuine
reason to de-platform them.
- It definitely feels illegal.
That's for sure.
- It definitely feels illegal!
This definitely shouldn't feel illegal,
whatever they're doing.
- Like, that's literally
like being like, you know,
"I'll give you $10 JK it's 10 cents."
You know, it's literally that.
- I just don't understand what sick fuck,
like builds up this audience, right?
And then just is like, "All right,
I'm just going to take their
money," like, you know.
- Well again that's, what's
the shitty thing, right.
It's like, it's built on a trust system.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Your viewers trust you as a personality.
- [Connor] It's so shat. It's so shat.
- They'll listen to
anything you say, right.
Being like, "Oh, well, if my
favorite content creators says,
I should do this, I
should probably do this."
And, so I feel it works both ways, right?
- [Connor] Yeah. Yeah.
- It's like, obviously
influencers are kind
of fucked in a sense,
- [Connor] Yeah.
because they're literally taking advantage
of a fan base that trusts them.
But, at the same time,
the viewers aren't really
thinking for themselves, right?
They're not thinking like,
hmm, this might be a scam.
- It's hard. Right?
Cause you do like, it's unfortunate.
People do build up trust.
- Yeah.
And, for some reason, they trusted someone
with the name FaZe in front of their name.
- Yeah. Why.
- Yeah.
- You know, it's just, it's sad, man.
I just, the idea of someone
like looking up to this,
this person who plays
Fortnite or whatever.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Fortnite. (Connor laughs)
- We clearly are very knowledgeable
about what FaZe Clan does.
- You know and a-
- This is the most gamer
one out of us three
and even he's having
trouble describing them.
- It's that side of gaming that is
blatantly marketed towards,
you know, under 16 year olds.
I'm not really into that.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- You know, and it's sad.
It's just really sad.
I just don't understand
how you could go to
a meet and greet ever and
look, your fans in the eye,
and be like, I'm so glad to meet you.
It's like, no you're fucking not.
- Thank you for changing my life.
- They're just a fucking
wallet, when you need them.
You know what I mean?
Like it's one thing to
like e-beg in various ways.
But like, I think this is just like a-
- It's e-steal isn't it?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- You're just like stealing, it's fucked.
- 'Cause like what blows my
mind hearing the story is that
there are so many legitimate
ways to make money
that is not this shady.
- [Connor] Yeah.
I mean fuck you know,
like how much did Logan Paul and Jake Paul
make from like a fucking
boxing match, right?
- That's what blows my mind-
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Is that Logan Paul
must have made what, 20,
$30 million from that fight?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And then he's here promoting
dink donk, coin of dinged,
whatever it is, fucking coin.
- Some dumb ass fucking name.
- It's like, what are you doing, man?
You're already fucking rich as shit.
Do you really need to do this?
Like, this is what blows my mind.
I don't understand.
- Yeah, cause, like I've
thought that, you know,
as much as they are
scumbags and everything,
They're also like fucking geniuses
for being able to monetize
how fucking hated they are.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Because they've made millions
from doing boxing matches.
- [Connor] Yeah. Right.
- So I'm just like, well, okay.
That was pretty clever.
I'll give you the rep for,
you know, monetizing your-
- At least you're putting
your body on the line, right?
- Yeah monetizing you being a scumbag.
- Yeah.
- But then there's just
this, which is, you know,
it's not nowhere near as
profitable as getting punched
in the face, and I'd much
rather get punched in the face.
Thank you very much, (Joey
laughs) honestly, honestly.
- Yeah no, honestly.
Jeez.
- If I have the options to
get punched in the face,
or do the sponsorship,
I'd be like punch me
in the face every time.
(Garnt laughs)
- Do I get paid the same amount?
- Yeah same amount.
(indistinct)
- It's just a flesh wound.
- It's like the would you rather, right?
Would you rather get punched
in the face for $20 million
or scam people out of crypto for $50,000?
- Or do an illegal act?
(laughing)
Which would you rather do?
- Man, it's just sad.
The whole thing is so
sad every time I think.
Oh yeah, YouTube is, a lot
of them are pretty bad huh?
- And guaranteed as well.
Like, when this does break
out into like, the mainstream,
if it hasn't fucking already,
like news outlets are going to pick it up,
they're going to be like,
"These Youtubers are
doing blah, blah, blah."
And you know what sucks is that, yeah,
they might be douche bags.
But, at the end of the day,
a lot of these guys are
like the faces of YouTube.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- So seeing them, you know,
being like represented of YouTube
as a whole and doing
these like shitty things,
it's going to make us look like shit.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Even though we're sitting here,
literally laughing at them
for being how fucking dumb they were.
- Yeah it sucks.
- I mean I always look
at that side of YouTube
and it's just so alien to me.
Cause I don't normally keep up with like,
how can I say like, the kind of like side
of YouTube, which is mostly like,
I guess based in LA
and mostly like aimed towards, yeah, like-
- The LA YouTube scene, right?
- Yeah.
The LA YouTube scene is just like-
- It's notorious of just being insane.
- It is like a different world to me.
I don't get it sometimes.
Yeah. And I would like to say
that they don't obviously
represent all of YouTube, but I think-
- No.
- That's obvious to like
most of our audience,
because I feel like there's
very little audience-
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Like crossover between our stuff
and their stuff to begin with.
- Oh. Yeah, yeah, yeah. No.
But, that's why I'm holding
Trash Taste coin, guys.
Make sure to have those diamonds.
- TT coin! The TT coin.
- Hold your diamond hands.
Trash Taste, fucking.
Could you imagine?
- Monkey coin rise up.
- Monkey coin!
(laughing)
- Monkey coin.
That'll be it.
That's probably already
a thing to be fair.
- [Joey] Probably.
- There's so many coins.
- [Joey] Well probably.
- My God.
What else you guys been up to, huh?
- Well I see what you guys have been up to
and that's getting your
first vaccine shot.
That was broadcasted live
- Oh yeah. We did do that.
- On my Japanese television.
- [Joey] That's all right.
I got like fucking stared down by like
the Minister of Health or whatever he was.
- Yeah, yeah. The-
- What was he again?
- Well, I guess the
Anthony Fauci of Japan.
- Yes, essentially.
- Yeah.
- But yeah, we got a,
is it weird to say that
our vaccine was sponsored?
- This vaccine is sponsored by.
- And, it was in a sense.
It kind of was, but not really.
- It was, and it wasn't.
- I mean, you know, I don't know what-
- We didn't get paid to get vaccines.
So I guess it wasn't sponsored.
- Yeah, so the, the
company that we work for,
it's obviously a
subsidiary of a subsidiary,
which is owned by Kadokawa.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
And Kadokawa in Japan, you know,
I disagree with this.
They were only really
giving the vaccines out
to big companies with over a
thousand employees, I think.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- To give so that they could
give it to their employees.
But, I just think that
you should just give it
to anyone who wants it.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Cause apparently, you know, people,
all the population here haven't
been too receptive to it.
- [Garnt] No.
- They haven't been
taking it much, whatever.
So yeah. They had it.
And, I believe Kadokawa, was like,
"All right, well let's
make it a press event."
And so.
- Yeah because Dwango,
which is the company
that owns Niconico,
which is like, the Japanese
YouTube, essentially.
- [Connor] Yep.
- They wanted to do this
program where they were like,
we need to get foreigners
living in Japan vaccined.
Because, you know.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- We want to show that off are being like,
"It doesn't matter if you're a foreigner,
you can get vaccined here guys, yeah."
Like, like every foreigner
living here, isn't like,
can you just give me the
fucking vaccine already?
- Yeah. Yeah. Exactly.
- Like we know the vaccine exists.
So yeah.
They were like, "Well,
Trash Tastes has a lot
of foreigners in it."
- Yeah.
So they were like, "Yeah,
you can have the vaccine,
if you go on TV."
And I was thinking like,
fuck well it could be
months before I get it here.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I don't know why I'm
going to get it. You know?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
You know, it's not like
I've never done this before.
Sure.
Fuck it, I'll get stabbed on TV.
- Yeah. At least again,
at least you weren't given
the death glare, right?
On TV?
- Yeah well so what happened was
that we turn up to this place,
and we fill out a form
and there's already like,
people like shuffling us around.
And like, obviously it's
a very strange experience
if you've never been
on like a press thing.
And to be honest, we haven't been on many,
but essentially you turn up at a place.
And then like a group
of 10 people are like,
"Come here, come here.
Do this thing. Do this thing."
And then they're shoving you around.
And you're just like,
"All right, okay.
I'll just keep following."
And then you like, "Just
fill out this form.
Fill it out now."
"All right. Okay. Fuck it."
"Oh, come here, come here.
You gotta get to do this."
And then I'm like, "All right,
well, all right, well shit.
What's going on? Fuck.
- Yeah.
Meanwhile, this entire time,
this entire thing is live-streamed
- [Connor] Yeah.
On Niconico in front of,
I think it was like 35,000 people.
- Yeah. Something like that.
- Yeah.
I don't know what 35,000
people are just watched.
Are just sitting there watching
people getting vaccinated.
- Right?
It's so weird.
- I'm not sure if it was
total views of live viewers,
but it was a lot.
- Yeah.
- It was live views.
- Yeah, and so-
- But, I saw how many comments there were
and just like completely
filled up the screen.
- Yeah.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- So with Niconico,
it's not like YouTube comments
where you can read them down
on like on like the bottom.
Like, if you comment something it like
appears live on the feed.
- It's pretty cool, but
also really distracting.
- Yeah it's really distracting.
- It's a cool feature I think.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. So then we get shuffled across
to this other room with like 20 cameras,
and a bunch of people and me and Joey
just looked so out of place
because everyone is wearing suits.
And we're just like, "All right."
- And Connor and I are
rocking in our JoJo shirts.
- Yeah we were in JoJo shirts,
because I was like "If I'm going TV,
I'm wearing JoJo merch."
And then they were like, "Sit down here."
And, I was like, "Okay, cool."
And literally like two seconds later
after they told us to sit down,
the Health Minister-
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Comes around the corner and like,
like Emperor Palpatine,
just stares us down.
Like, "Yes."
- Yeah what the fuck was
up with that death stare
he gave you guys?
(Joey laughs)
- So, so before that as well right.
- Before that. Yeah.
- He's like, he's like, "How was it?"
And we were, and Joey,
didn't say anything.
- No. He looked at me and
he was, like, in English,
he was like, "How was it?"
And I'm like, I was this
close to being like,
"Bro, I literally just walked in."
(laughing)
Like we haven't gotten it yet.
We're waiting.
- Yeah, so Joey, he didn't respond.
And we were really awkward,
because we were like confused.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And then, as he's walking.
I'm like, "Oh, we haven't had it yet."
And he goes, "Oh," and
then just walks off.
But then has a five minute conversation
with the Japanese cosplayers.
And me and Joey are like,
"All right, well. Okay."
- All right. Should we go get it now?
- Wait, wait.
There were Japanese cosplayers there?
- Yeah there was someone
from Final Fantasy Seven
next to me, just chilling.
- Just in cosplay?
- In cosplay.
- Yeah. In cosplay.
(laughing)
- It was really strange.
- Was this like a vaccine like event,
or was this a fucking
anime expo or something?
- I think, I think the event was to like-
- They were Japanese influencers.
- Yeah. They Japanese influencers.
- Oh. Okay.
- So it was like foreign influencers,
Japanese influencers, musicians, talents,
all that kind of stuff.
- So they just came in costume?
- Yeah. They came in costume.
- That's so weird!
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Well, I think while we
don't really give a shit,
I think the Japanese talent very much-
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Care about upholding the image.
- [Joey] Yeah like the image. Yeah.
- [Garnt] Okay. Yeah.
- And, me and Joey were like fuck it.
We're just tell them joke.
I guess that's upholding the image. Right?
- Yeah.
And then, when I was getting the vaccine
from my periphery, like I
could see from my periphery,
just the Health Minister
staring down at me, like.
- [Connor] It was this really funny video
of like four angles of this guy
just staring at Joey
with like a whole press team behind him.
(Joey laughs)
It was really bizarre.
- It looks so fucking ominous.
- It was really ominous.
- It was like a scene from
like fucking JoJo or something.
- It looked like a parody.
Like when, especially when
they like zoom in on you,
I was just like, this
is like built for memes.
- And it's like, "Yes, the Anime Man."
- Like literally, Emporer
Palpatine just walking
around with his like subordinates.
- Yeah. It's like, "Do it!"
(laughing)
- "Snap him!"
- Yeah, cause when I went,
because I went like a
few hours afterwards,
because I was busy winning
a Shadowverse tournament
at the time.
- GG by the way.
- But yeah,
I came in afterwards, and it
was like pretty chill for me.
I didn't have any cameras, no interview.
Did you guys have to do
interviews or anything like that?
- No, we just went on like
a livestream afterwards
and said, watch Trash Tastes.
- Yeah. Did you, did you
have to sit in front of like
there was like a weird like shrine
looking thing after you got the shot?
- No.
- [Connor] A shrine.
- So after we got the shot, one of the,
there was like seven camera angles
on this Niconico live stream.
But one of the camera angles was through,
I was on this table and it was through
these like Torii gates.
- [Garnt] Right.
- It was a really shit angle.
- Okay.
- You could barely see our faces,
but basically they were like,
once we got the shots done,
we came out, and they were like,
"Oh, sit down and give us a couple
of like words on how your experience was."
So Connor and I got sat in
front of this Torii shrine.
And they were like, "How was it?"
And I was like, "Its a
fucking needle, wasn't it?"
I've done this before, dude.
It's just, it's just the vaccine.
But then, we use that as the opportunity
to be like watch Trash Taste.
- Oh really?
- Yeah.
- Damn, promoting Trash
Tastes during a vaccine.
- Yeah, I guarantee you,
most of them didn't
understand what we said.
- No.
- But, it's all right.
It's the thought that counts.
- I saw Sydney's clip
where went in front of it,
and she just says, yeah,
I'm an aero-gay YouTuber.
(laughing)
And she literally said that and
the comments were just like,
what?
Everyone thought she was like
a JAV actress or something.
- Oh my God
- Wow.
- Poor choice of words.
But, yeah, I mean.
- So yeah, I guess I traded,
you know, I let them,
we were Guinea pigs for the press
so that we could get vaccines.
- Worth it. Honestly.
- Yeah.
Honestly like when, when we got the,
when we got like the offer from Meilyne,
like Meilyne just messages
us one day and was like,
"Guys, good news.
I can secure you guys a vaccine."
And we're just like, "Great."
Well, as you know, as, you know,
as hopefully many companies
are getting vaccinated
right now.
That's fucking brilliant.
And then, she was like,
"But there's a catch."
(Joey laughs)
I was like, "What'd you mean
there's a fucking catch?
I'm just, I just want to get vaccinated."
- Yeah.
- It's like, "Well you can get it
if you appear on Niconico
and livestream it."
I'm just like, "What kind of
sponsorship offer is this?
This is like literally the
weirdest sponsorship offer
I've ever heard in my life."
- We've never done anything with Niconico.
- It's not really a sponsorship.
We didn't have to do much, just turn up.
- It kind of felt like it at the time,
but it wasn't technically
a sponsorship offer, but-
- Slowly getting there.
First jab complete.
Next one in the end of this month.
- Yeah. End of this month.
- Yeah.
- And then, we'll be fully 5G'd up.
- Yeah. Fully 5G positive.
- I'm honestly impressed,
because it just seemed
like a switch just like flicked
in like the Japanese vaccination program.
- Yeah.
- And like, we went from no vaccines
to everyone's getting a vaccine now.
- Well yeah, because I think its
because the government finally realized.
They were like, "Olympics is a month away,
and no one's been vaccinated yet."
- They were like, yeah
that's not a good look.
- We should probably do
something about that.
- Yeah, because Japan, normally isn't,
isn't used to really having eyes on them.
- [Joey] No.
- They don't really kind
of very much like that.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And now they have all
the eyes on them watching.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Literally everything
they do and criticizing it.
So they're not, I don't think
they're like used to it.
- Yeah. But-
- America is like, "First time, huh?"
(all laugh)
- I got these like really
fucking awful back pains.
- [Connor] Did you?
- Like the day after I
got the vaccine shot.
Like, you know,
most of the time it's
like, oh my, you know,
my left arm or whatever
arm you got was sore,
only I got it on the
left arm and this entire
part was just aching, like fucking crazy.
- Yeah.
- And I was like, I'm feeling sleepy.
I'm feeling drowsy.
Meanwhile, I woke up the next day.
And I was like, I feel like someone just
like drop kicked me in the back.
(laughing)
I don't know, why.
- So strange I've never heard anyone say
they got back pain.
- It's weird right?
And, it's like only me
and Aki are the only ones
that have got this side effect.
Everyone else was just like-
- Bro if I scream too loudly, you might,
you might fucking turn into a titan.
- I was about to say.
Obviously you were just injected
with that fucking titan juice.
- That's probably why.
That's probably why-
(Connor screaming)
- That's why the health
minister was there.
- I was going to say that.
He better not be going fucking titan.
- It's like they give you the vaccine,
with a bottle the wine there.
We got to put spoiler
warnings for that, that joke.
- Oh yeah.
- It was like fucking
Historia looking at me, right.
It's just like you better
turn into a fucking titan
I swear to god.
- We're going to put a
spoiler warning, fuck.
- [Joey] Yeah.
It's probably the first
ever just casual spoiler
we've ever done.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- This episode is sponsored by Bokksu.
What is this?
Bokksu!
(Joey laughs)
What Joey?
- Nothing.
- Isn't that the fabled
premium Japanese snack box
subscription services that deliver snacks
straight from Japan to your door
and offers free shipping to the US?
- How do you guys know this?
What?
- Someone is transmitting
some information right now
directly to my brain.
Here it comes again.
For those of you who would like
to indulge in the wonderful
snacks Japan has to offer.
This is for you.
- I personally recommend this one,
this Suika gummies.
Garnt, have you tried these?
- I can't control it!
- [Connor] So use coupon
code, TrashTaste20,
to get 20% off your first authentic
Japanese snack box from Bokksu.
Take advantage of this limited time offer.
- Don't worry Garnt, I think
this will help you out.
- Mmm! I feel a lot better now.
- Sounds delicious.
- Back to the show.
- But when I, when I got my jab,
I was extremely tired of the day of.
And, I couldn't do anything.
So, I decided I was
going to watch a TV show.
It was an animation.
Not quite an anime.
- [Joey] Oh?
- Or, technically an
anime, technically in Japan
that is an anime.
- That is an anime.
- Yeah. I watched Invincible.
(instrumental music)
(blood splatters)
- Oh Okay.
- Is it good?
- Oh my God. It's amazing.
- Really?
- It's really good.
- It's fucking amazing.
- I need to watch it.
- It's so good.
- I'm like, there must be a reason
why this show's getting memed a lot.
- It's really good.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I was really blown away by how
just incredible it was.
Like everything
- Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Cut to title screen right now.
(exciting music)
Not invincible. Oh yeah.
Incredible. Sorry.
(all laugh)
- I was like, what are you fucking doing?.
- I was like, oh, I love the Disney movie.
- The Incredibles.
- Oh, I love the Disney movie.
- Not Pixar. Fuck.
- Yeah, it was great.
I mean, fuck man, it's so good.
I just, I want season two now.
- Can you sell it to me?
Like, what's it about?
I know it's about superheroes.
- Yeah.
- It's kind of hard to sell
it without spoiling it.
- Okay.
- Because there's a massive spoiler
in the very first episode.
- Right. It's one of those things
that it is literally the best show
to experience knowing nothing.
- Okay. Okay.
- Cause I almost think,
that me seeing some of the memes
spoiled a bit for me.
- [Joey] Oh really?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- But, because I imagined
those twists would have been
so much more impactful if I
didn't know they were coming,
but I knew they were coming,
because I saw the memes.
But, if anyone, I'm not going
to talk too much about it.
I will just say that it is
probably one of the best TV shows
I've watched in like the past year.
- [Joey] Wow.
- It is really fucking good.
- How many episodes is it?
- Eight.
- It's only 10.
Is it eight?
- Eight.
- Eight episodes, and
they're 45 minutes long.
- Okay. Okay.
- And it's, it's just amazing.
Like it's everything is fucking-
- Did you watch The Boys at all?
- I did not.
- Okay.
- It's very similar to The Boys.
- It's very similar to The Boys,
which is funny that they are both
like Amazon Prime exclusives.
- Right. Right.
- But, if you didn't watch
The Boys, that's fine.
You just, it's a,
I'd say a more brutal take on
the superhero genre, maybe.
- I heard The Boys is like
super fucking gory, right?
- [Connor] Oh yeah.
- Yeah.
- I'd say like The Boys
is more like humory.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Lot more humor involved,
whereas Invincible is
just like pretty brutal at times.
- Just brutal. Yeah.
Invincible was less of
like a, like a parody
or like a subversion
of the superhero genre
and more of just like, ah,
I don't know how to like,
describe it without spoiling
major plot points, so.
- Like a deconstruction maybe?
- I wouldn't say it was a deconstruction.
- It's just like, you
know, if realistically,
if superheroes are just
randomly like powers
that were given out, some
people are going to be assholes.
- [Joey] Right, right, right.
Okay. Okay.
- Not that that's what
happens here, but it's again,
I don't want to talk about it
much other than it is amazing.
I've watched it.
Anyone watching this, if you've been,
you've been thinking about
it, 100% go watch it.
- Yeah. I've definitely
been thinking about that
and the boys, so yeah.
- Yeah.
You should watch both because I like
with watching invincible,
it was the first time.
I remember after I finished the season
or finished the series,
it was the first time
I had like an episode
just really shock me.
Because like, you know,
we watch a lot of anime.
We read a lot of media.
And so it's been the
first time in a long time
where something has just
shocked me in that way,
because I just it's something
that I just hadn't seen before.
- Okay.
- So that's why I think
it's really worth watching
and watch it before
everyone starts jumping
on this trend and everyone starts like
trying to fucking rip
them off or something.
Or do their own take on it.
- It was a comic before
if I'm not mistaken,
- Yeah. It was a comic before.
And like, from what I've heard
and I've been told, like,
we haven't really had too many
like comic book adaptations outside
of the very safe family
friendly Marvel owned ones.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- What I've been told and
what my friends tell me,
like there's so many good stories
in the comic books that
have just not been touched.
Like, so many mature ones as well.
And, I'm hoping that this will lead
to more adaptations of
really fucking mature comics
because it's amazing.
- Yeah. I feel the last time we got
like a mature comic adaptation
that I thought was pretty
good or like, it wasn't good,
but it was really
entertaining was Sin City.
- I never watched that.
- Yeah.
- The movie?
- Yeah. That was originally
based off a comic.
- Was it?
- Yeah.
- I like Watchmen in the movie.
I like that.
- Yeah.
- I like that movie.
(Garnt laughs)
- I like how you just like
really whispered that.
I like Watchmen.
- I feel like people
don't like that movie.
- Isn't it Watchmen?
- Watchmen. Yeah. It's Watchmen.
- Watchman.
- Watchman. A watch man.
- It's Inspector Gadget.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- No. Cause like I heard the same thing
about Sin City as well,
because like a lot of people,
like, "No. It was crap,"
you know, it was like, it
was over the top, you know,
all that kind of stuff.
But, I'm like, isn't it
supposed to be over the top?
- [Connor] Yeah.
- It's a comic book.
- I'm sure there's a bunch
of comic book aficionados
in the comment section that would tell us,
"Actually, there's these
amazing adaptations out there.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, because I heard that Watchmen was
just really hated by
everyone who read the comics,
and I watched it and I was like,
I thought it was a good movie.
I have no idea about the source material.
Same thing with a V for Vendetta as well.
- [Connor] Love V for Vendetta.
- Yeah. I fucking love that movie.
And apparently comic
book readers hated it.
I don't know why.
Maybe they have a legitimate reason.
- I feel that's the
same with like anything.
- From what I know it
could be fucking total-
- Bro, you're literally like calling out
manga readers, right now.
(Garnt laughs)
- Yeah. It's literally
just all manga readers
being like, "Oh no, it wasn't that good.
The manga was way better.
Because literally the
comic book was wat better."
- As an anime fan, I know how it is.
- As a manga reader, I know how it is.
- I know we're going from
topic to topic fast here,
but speaking of that kind of topic
of manga and anime
adaptations and whatnot,
and not getting it right.
I recently watched and
read Records of Ragnarok.
- Okay.
- And know there's gonna be,
cause when I was live
streaming, people were like,
"Oh, well Netflix paid you to react to it.
So you can't say a bad thing about it."
No, that's not true.
- [Joey] That's not true.
- We can say bad things about
it, and I'm going to do that.
So yeah. With, with that as well.
Yeah. We just reacted to it.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It wasn't like you
have to say good thing.
It was like react to it.
But you know, if you please,
please don't be too mean, you know.
- Yeah. "Don't like rip us to shreds."
- And like-
- I'm not going to be like, "Oh thank you
for bringing me here, Netflix.
Wow. This looks like shit."
But like, when we're talking about it,
I will give my honest
opinions on the show.
- Yeah. To be fair, the scenes
that we did react to were
probably the better scenes.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. They definitely showed us
the better fight of the two,
even then it was like, you
know, it was all right.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. It was-
- Especially compared to
the manga, it was yeah.
- Cause, cause like I will say this.
Yeah. We, you know, we obviously
were sponsored by Netflix
to react to it.
And we tried to give like, I mean,
I was honestly hype
for the show in general
because I'm a huge fan of the manga.
So, I was pretty hype.
- Same.
- And, we were obviously shown,
we weren't showed the entire episode.
We were shown just like clips of it.
- Like five minutes of it, I think.
- Like same thing as
like the trailer. Right?
- Yeah.
- And you know, I was, I honestly-
- I think the opening
to Records of Ragnarok
was fucking hype.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It's Maximum the Hormone.
- Maximum the Hormone.
- Which is the Death
Note's second opening.
(Connor screams)
So, it was fucking hype.
- Yeah, exactly.
And I honestly went
into it with high hopes.
- Yeah.
Because, why wouldn't I?
And having, 'cause I watched
the final product as well.
And I, yeah. I mean,
I will say I am disappointed
with how it was adapted
because I feel like the fights
deserved better treatments
and I don't know what happened
in the production process
or what's kind of went
on behind the scenes,
but it wasn't the final product
that I was personally hoping for.
- Yeah.
- I think it was fine.
Like I saw a lot of YouTube videos
where people were like,
"It's fucking awful.
Don't support this shit. It's terrible."
I was like, you don't want like,
it's still better than
a lot of adaptations
we've had like in recent memory, you know.
Like, I feel like they're bastardized
One Punch Man season two
way more than this did.
- Really?
I don't think so.
- I don't, man, some of
the One Punch Man fights
were so appalling in season two.
- Yeah. But I feel like, ah, I dunno.
It's a tough one.
Because, for both of them,
I would recommend the
manga over the anime.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Definitely.
- No. Yeah. 100%.
- But, even then reading
Records of Ragnarok going back,
I'm like, yeah, this is cool.
And, you could do this anime adaptation
the way that I think people wanted,
but it's just never going to happen.
- [Joey] No.
- Like I don't think we're ever going
to get the Record of Ragnarok adaptation
people wanted. Like-
- [Garnt] No.
- I don't think the story is that good
where a company would
believe in it enough.
Like, I read it. Right?
And it's cool.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- But like the story's fine.
- There isn't much of a story.
- It's literally just a battle show.
- Yeah.
- Which is fine. It's cool.
But, I was sitting there and I'm like,
I could see why, you know,
this is never gonna be
the most popular manga.
Like this is never going
to be in like the top 10.
You know what I mean?
- It purely just builds
itself off like hype.
- Am I wrong in saying that?
- Well, it doesn't need
to be in the top 10
to get a decent adaptation.
I mean, you know,
we can talk about the Berserk adaptation.
That's definitely a top 10 manga.
- [Connor] Sure. Sure.
- And look at the
adaptations it got, right?
(indistinct)
- I've gotten so used
to the current climate
of adaptations we've been getting
and I'm like, I just
couldn't see like a show
that is literally all
fighting like 24 minutes
been done justice.
Where are anime is right now?
- Well, I would say, look at
God of High School, right?
- [Connor] Yeah.
God of High School, has a very mid story.
The story of the anime
was very mid as well,
but my fucking God,
the fight scenes and the
animation were absolutely amazing.
Right?
And I feel like God of High School
and Records of Ragnarok
have a lot of similarities.
And I mean, they're both
just like tournament arc,
the anime.
- But the God of High
School had a big focus
on martial arts and like,
that kind of movement.
And, I feel like that was specific
to that director who knew very much-
- Yeah. I mean the director
was a very fucking talented
'cause it's the same guy
who did Jujutsu Kaisen,
but so I mean, I'm saying this
that, you know, it could
have got a good adaptation,
but unfortunately I don't think it got.
- I think it's the most
five out of 10 adaptation.
- Really?
Records of Ragnarok.
Yeah. It's pretty much
bog standard, I thought.
Like it's a little, at
times it was disappointing,
But, when I read the manga, I was like,
well, it kind of gives
you the same feeling.
I'm not going to lie.
- Really?
- Genuinely.
- I thought the like the manga
art was fucking incredible-
- [Connor] Yeah. It is, but it's-
- Which is, which is why like,
you've already sold me on this. Yeah.
It's a mediocre story
because it's just a
fucking tournament arc,
but it's just dumb fun.
It's cool.
- Yeah.
- It's like, it's just a
lot of fun and then like-
- It just hypes the wrong story.
- I know I'm going to get for this.
I read both the,
so there's a fight between
Adam of Adam and Eve, and Zeus,
- [Joey] And Zeus.
- and everyone was like,
"This is the most epic fight of all time."
And, I was like, "Yeah, it's pretty good."
And I was reading it and I was just like,
"I actually think it
was better in the anime,
even though it wasn't even that good."
- Are you for real?
- Yeah.
- Are you actually for real?
- That fucking screenshot
like fucking, you know,
where the panel loads.
- Yeah.
- I'm like, it's literally
like reading the manga.
It's literally reading the manga-
- Oh my God.
- With pretty animated slides.
- Welcome to Trash Takes, everybody.
What is this take I'm hearing right now?
- I just think that-
- You are the guy who couldn't get over
the fucking like animated manga
in like, what was it?
Way of the Househusband?
And here you are in an actual
anime that needs animation
because it's an action
anime, and you prefer it?
- I realize this is
making me look terrible.
I remember, because that's
just the way it was.
There was some animation that I was like,
"I don't like how this
looks," but I, this one,
they literally just showed screenshots
of the fucking fight in the manga.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And I'm like, you know what,
at least they just gave up.
At least they were like, you know what?
Just don't even try.
- What are you talking about?
- I genuinely, I wish I wish I was joking,
because I know this is weird,
but I genuinely didn't care.
I was like, that's fine.
- Wait. So you prefer the anime
adaptation of that fight to-
- So I watched the anime
and then I read the manga.
It might've been an order thing, but yeah.
I was like, yeah, I think I
just preferred watching the-
- Nah. You're on crack, dude.
You're on crack.
- I really liked the music
and the voice acting.
It added so much to it too.
- What?
- I've never fucking heard that,
an opinion that's just so wrong.
I don't like-
- I'm to get grilled for this. I know.
- I want to know if there's
a single fucking person
watching this right now that
will actually agree with you.
- Who's like, "Yeah. Yeah. Finally.
Finally, I'm not the only one."
- It's just like, I know that like
when you look at it, you're like,
this looks better, but I don't know.
It's personal preference.
I just thought that when I
was watching it, I was like,
I think this deserves to be like,
have like music, voice acting.
I don't know why.
I just enjoyed that more.
Like I was, when I carried
on reading the manga,
I thought this is good.
But like, I actually wanted it
to just see the animation of it.
- This is the guy who
watches Seven Deadly Sins
season three, and is just like-
- [Connor] No!
- You know what? It's probably
better than the manga.
- That's probably better than the manga.
- See, that's what I'm saying, right?
Would I rather, what we get
is just like the manga colored
or would I rather Seven
Deadly Sins, season three?
Fuck no.
Get that out of here.
They literally made the art 10 times worse
than it is in the manga.
At least they just took the
fucking art from the manga.
- So, if I had literally grabbed the manga
and colored it in and
then played some music
as you read it.
- And voice acting. Yeah.
If you literally can't animate it, don't.
Just do that.
Like, you know what I mean? Like-
- Just do the old cell like movements.
(Joey yells)
- Well, it's like fucking, what is it?
I love the like CircleTunes
animation on YouTube.
Right? Where you just pop, do that.
- Yeah. Just move it around. Yeah.
- Just fucking do that, bro.
- Oh my God.
- I mean, I-
- Genuinely, I don't know why
I know it sounds strange
because I guess I've
just become so detached
to giving a shit, where
like these people seem
to like fucking seethe
weekly about manga art
not being adapted properly.
And, it's like.
- No. No. I get that.
- I get that.
- Like, that's obviously
taking it too far.
I know that this
obviously isn't that good,
but also at the same time, I'm like,
have we not learned that this
is always, this is the norm.
Like, this is what we're getting.
- I mean, I don't think so,
because I feel like with
anime art and manga art,
it's two totally different mediums, right?
And that's, I fell like-
- It still has to look close enough.
- Yeah, because I feel like, for example,
I'm bringing up an another example now
and I'm talking about
Junji Ito adaptations,
because you, did you watch the Junji Ito?
- Yeah, exactly.
Did you watch the Junji Ito,
like the short story adaptation?
I can't remember what it was called.
- Yes. Unfortunately I did.
- Yeah. That was literally
just like copying the manga
page panel by panel, by panel,
but there's just-
- And then, making it underwhelming.
- Yeah.
And then, just making it
completely underwhelming.
And, that's just because
the arcs just couldn't be
transferred over to the big screen
or like, it just wasn't enough detail.
- I'm so sad about that anime.
- And the art.
- I find that with fights,
I find them so much more frustrating
to figure out reading a
manga than in an anime.
- I get that.
- Because there's some
fights where I'm like, wait,
what the fuck is going on?
- No. No. I get that.
But the thing is the
Zeus versus Adam fight
in the manga is very
easily understandable.
- Yeah.
- No. I know. I know.
- You know exactly what's happening.
- It's basically just two
dudes punching the shit
out of each other.
How can you fuck that up?
How do you not?
How do you not know what's going on there?
- We're not talking about
like the Demon Slayer
fucking room rotating fight, right?
- [Connor] No. I know. I know. I know.
- It's literally just,
you're in a fucking stadium, you know?
- It was like, I was like, all right,
and so I read the manga.
And I'm like, yep, it's just two dudes.
like they were literally
just like aura, aura,
auraing each other.
And I'm like, what about this were people
like coming to the manga on?
I'm like, it's literally just like people
just pumped like fists,
the exact same page over and over again.
- People just like
detailed fights in manga-
- [Connor] I guess.
- I guess. Yeah.
- I appreciate it. I look at it.
I'm like, "That's nice."
But also I just, I just, I want the voice
- So, did you enjoy the anime, then?
- Yeah, I had a great time with it.
You know, like people
are it's unwatchable.
It's a good show.
- It's not unwatchable.
- It's not,
- It's so easy to turn your
brain off and enjoy that show.
- Yeah.
- It's not to the point
where it's unwatchable,
but I feel like it took
like a really good manga
and made it an average show.
That's how I feel.
That's my honest opinion.
- Yeah. I feel like the
manga is kind of average.
- You think so?
- Reading it I'm like, "You know what?
After the first two fights
or every single fight after
I think there's three
more fights after that,
I predicted who was
going to win immediately.
Just based off how they entered.
It was so obvious.
Like the latest fight
in the manga as well.
The one that's been finished
was so obviously that
the guy was going to lose
from the start that I
was totally uninvested.
- Just talking about.
I haven't read the latest manga.
- I haven't read the
latest chapter either.
- I haven't read like
the latest fight, so.
- Well, what was the last fight
that you saw in the manga?
- It was a Jack the
Ripper was the one I saw.
- I loved that fight.
- That was a great fight.
- But, I knew that Jack the
Ripper was going to win.
It was very obvious he was going to win.
- Wow, spoilers.
- Spoilers.
The next fight after that fight,
I think you'll immediately be able to tell
who's going to win within
like the first two chapters.
- I mean, you know.
I'd be lying if I said
that I didn't foresee
some of the fights.
- But, that's what I
thought was so good about
that's genuinely, everyone's like,
"It's the art about Adam and
Zeus fight that was the best.
I don't think that was the
best part about Adam and Zeus.
Adam and Zeus, I didn't
know until the last moment
who was going to win that fight.
- [Joey] Right. Right.
- There's that, and it was just,
I loved how the flight just
evolved and progressed.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- It's basically every trope
about like an anime fight
put into this one fight, but
just like expanded to 10 or 11,
like it was just pure, macho fun.
- Yeah.
- And it, you know, it doesn't
require a lot of thinking.
It doesn't require a lot of brain.
It's just fun.
And that's what I love
about Records of Ragnorok.
It like, takes out all the bullshit,
just like we don't,
we know you don't care about story.
We know you don't give a
about story, here, hit it.
Let me just give you fights
and fights and fights.
And that's what I love about.
You know?
- Yeah.
- But that's where I felt
that when everyone was saying,
"Oh, it's the art, it's the fights."
And I'm like, it is.
But like, I think the really
good thing that it had going,
especially in the start.
And I think probably
what made it so appealing
to people is that the fights in the start
I genuinely had no idea
who was going to win.
I could not, I didn't have any idea.
And then I feel like after
the third fight especially,
I thought it was so boring.
And I was like, I sleep
and it was obvious he was
going to win from the start.
- Yeah. I feel like just the way
that that show was just constructed
in general was not meant for
like long form serialization.
- No.
- 'Cause again, it's like, oh cool.
Here's the 17th fight.
- Well, because of the
way that the show did it
in the start, it was
like, "Here's two guys.
None of them were bad guys. Second fight.
Here's two guys. Very strong.
None of them are bad guys.
Make your own mind up
who you want to root for.
Third fight.
This guy's the bad guy. Real bad.
No one likes him.
Third guy. Oh, this guy's the good guy.
Oh, he's real good."
And then the good guy wins and
then you're like all right.
And then, the fourth one, it's so obvious
he's trying to do the old switcheroo.
He's like, "Oh, he's the bad guy.
Oh he's going to, oh we
want him to lose." You know?
And it's so obvious.
- [Joey] Right.
- Because, he tries to sell
it so hard, sell the show.
Sorry. I'm very off of it.
But yeah, it's fine.
I feel like it definitely
got weaker, and I,
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And, even though I've caught up to it,
I don't know how much I'm
going to keep reading it,
because I feel like I've had enough.
I'm like, yeah, man,
I don't really care about keep reading it.
- I mean, for me,
I just read it whenever I'm
looking for some dumb, fun.
- Yeah.
- Switch my brain off because like what,
I feel like the biggest
difference between the manga
and the anime adaptation for me was that
the anime is just missing this intensity
that I kind of felt
when reading the manga.
And, I'm pretty sure it's just
because when you're reading manga,
you know, because of the
art, you can kind of like,
you can kind of just,
you feel this intensity 'cause like
you're filling in the gaps
with your mind. Right?
And that's how really manga
works for me, at least.
With anime, you don't, you know,
it's presented right in front of you,
because the movement is there. Right?
And that's why to me like,
imagine if One Punch Man season one got
the same adaptation as season two. Right?
What part of the big
appeal of One Punch Man,
the manga at least is the art
is fucking incredible. Right?
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And, I feel like just because you see
the difference between
season one and season two,
and just because season two
just feels so much more
flat compared to the manga.
And that's just because the story's there,
you've got the same story,
but just the intensity of the art-
- There's no impact, yeah.
- The intensity-
- I've already, I've
started, even though it was,
it was a slight disappointing.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I still love season
two of One Punch Man.
I really enjoyed it. Honestly.
- Oh my God.
- I love One Punch Man, man.
It's one of my favorite
manga and shows of all time.
Like I think this.
- I mean, I get that, but like-
- I love the story.
- I don't know how you
can watch season one-
- Oh my God.
- And being like that
was fucking incredible.
And then watch a show that
was half as good as one.
- Season one of Trash Takes, we find out
Connor doesn't have ears.
Season two of Trash Takes,
we find out Connor doesn't have eyes.
- No. I'm not saying.
I'm not saying.
- He's just turning into
fucking Helen Keller.
- I'm not saying that One Punch Man,
season two is not a downgrade. It is.
It's still a banger a show though.
It's still great.
Like, One Punch Man for me,
although the action was amazing,
it was like the amazing tiramisu
after your five course meal,
you know the animation right?
To me, it was always,
it was always the story in One Punch Man.
Like, 'cause it seems
like it doesn't have it,
but then season two,
they introduced Garou.
Garou, Garou, Garou?
- Garou.
- Yeah. Garou.
- Oh my God. I love that.
It is such a good, good
aspect in the story.
I love how it plays into it.
And then the manga now is amazing.
Like, I fucking love reading the manga.
- I don't think the story.
Well, I mean this is going
to one hot take to another.
All right?
Honestly, I don't think the story-
- Shit on one I love, Garnt. Do it.
Just shit on one I love.
Tell me I'm wrong.
- I don't know.
I don't think the story of One
Punch Man is like top tier.
I think it's a good story.
But like, if you're going to
talk about story from one,
I mean fucking Mob Psycho 100,
I think has a way better
story than One Punch Man.
- I have to agree with that.
- Yeah. I guess, but Mob
is more of a neater story.
Everything wraps up
nicely. Everything about-
- It just feels like it's more of a story,
and I'm not saying One Punch Man
doesn't have a story, obviously.
I think it has a pretty decent story.
- I would rank Mob higher
than One Punch Man.
- Yeah. By far by far.
Mob, to me is the full package.
- Yeah. Not by far, calm down.
Right, Garnt?
- It is. It is. It is.
- Not by far. Come on.
- Mob Psycho is like pretty
much the full package
on everything you want.
It's got a great animation.
It's got a very good story.
Very well written characters.
And I feel like One Punch Man-
- One Punch Man just kind of wrote
off a gimmick, essentially.
- It kind of like I liked-
- And, they used it.
They turned a gimmick
into a lovable story.
- They turned a gimmick
into a lovable story,
which I feel couldn't sustain itself.
- I don't know. I disagree.
I think the story right now is amazing.
- I'm not saying the story
is bad in One Punch Man.
- Yeah. Fuck you, Joey.
- I think it's great.
But, I think Mob Psycho
definitely had a better story.
- Well, Mob Psycho is finished.
- Yeah.
- And, One Punch Man's still going.
Scientist's tick check that.
Bigger length equals better story.
No, it means never
admit one piece is good.
No. I take that back.
- It's amazing.
- No. I don't know. I don't know.
Although I agree that Mob
Psycho 100 is probably
the strongest story.
There's something about One Punch Man,
season two that really gets me.
I don't know. It gets me going.
- [Garnt] It just gets you.
- It gets me going.
It gets me going.
- It's just your personal
preference, right?
- I guess so.
- You're entitled to your wrong opinion.
- Fuck you.
- Yeah. I mean, for me
season two was, it was okay.
It was okay. It was great.
I mean, I-
- Yeah, season two for
me, it was just like,
all right, time to read the manga.
- Even in the manga,
I feel like that arc
that season two adapted,
was one of the lesser
exciting parts of the story.
I feel like the real good
part of the story is what's-
- It's literally the arc after.
- Literally the arc after.
That's when the story
starts getting interesting.
But, I mean, there's like the issue is
that you got to deal with Saitoma
as, you know, as a story element.
And, I feel like he just hasn't,
or there hasn't been like the right way
to like deal with it.
Because, I feel like the
most interesting part
of One Punch Man, season two
and season three is Garou.
And, I feel like that was the element
that he added to try to save that.
But, Saitama's still still there,
and there's only so much you
can play off that as a concept.
- Season three? Is that just-
- I'm sorry. I'm saying if
season three did get adapted.
- We haven't heard anything
about that. Have we?
- No.
- It got, did it get announced?
- No, I don't think so.
- No.
- Did Mob Psycho season
three get announced?
- I don't think there's
enough for season three.
Is there?
There's from what I understand,
there's not that much left of mob psycho.
- I dunno. I didn't finish Mob Psycho.
- I don't know.
What, how does he know finish it?
- 'Cause he's the anime man.
- 'Cause, I just had not enough time.
Because I was reading other things.
- Brah.
- Brah. It's so good.
- Because I was reading
what is probably going
to be anime of the year, AKA Chainsawman.
- Oh God. Yeah.
That trailer dropped and it
like 10 million views on Twitter.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Oh my gosh.
- I mean,
if we're going to talk about a trailer
that made me nut, that's a
trailer that made me nut.
- Oh yeah.
That trailer definitely like,
they knew what they were doing.
- Yeah. I was like, "MAPPA,
you son of a bitch."
- You son of a bitch.
You did it again."
- You son of a bitch,
MAPPA, you did it again.
- Yeah. So what MAPPA were
doing Attack on Titan.
Right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And, they saw all those comments
that people were like, "Oh,
why couldn't they animate
Attack on Titan like this?
What's going on?"
- Well, Do you remember
the first Attack on Titan
season four trailer?
It looked fucking amazing.
- Yeah.
- But, like compared to the final product-
- That's what I'm scared of.
That's what I'm scared of.
- Yeah. That's what everybody's scared of.
- We also learned from like,
when Ken came on the podcast,
shout out to that episode,
he was telling us, you know,
it's not really about the studio.
It's about the guy in
charge and who he brings on.
- Yeah. It's about the director
and the team of animators.
Yeah.
- So, you know, if you
have good connections
and you can bring someone on,
I almost feel like the studio
almost doesn't matter, sometimes.
It's a slight indication,
but I feel like it's so inconsistent.
- No. Absolutely.
- Yeah. I mean, it's definitely.
a lot of it has got to do
with the team behind it
and director behind it.
I mean, we just talked
about Jujutsu Kaisen
also by MAPPA,
but that was like such
a well animated show,
even compared to like other MAPPA shows.
I think that's just mostly
because of the team behind it.
- Yeah.
- And, I'm hoping that Chainsaw
Man gets a good adaptation.
I haven't even read the fucking manga.
- I re-read the manga
when the trailer dropped.
- You now when you have those, those shows
or those, you know, properties.
I don't know what you
call them, (mumbles).
- IPs?
- IPs.
- IPs where you just know
they're going to be bangers.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And so you don't,
you're not like in a rush
to jump into it.
You're like, I know I've
got something coming.
- Yeah.
- I've got a little present
under the Christmas tree.
I can unwrap it anytime.
You know it's there.
You need like a 10 out of 10
in the waiting, just in case.
- [Joey] Yeah. Exactly.
- And that's definitely mine right now.
I'm like, I know it's coming.
I'm waiting for it.
- I'm just praying. I'm just going,
I'm also honestly-
- It's airing in the Fall, right?
Chainsawman? Is that this year?
- It's either this year
or early next year.
- Fuck, if it's this year, Jesus like it,
this year doesn't need another good anime.
My fucking God.
It's getting too much, now.
It's too much.
There's too much to watch.
- [Joey] I know. I know.
- I've not watched that much anime.
I just kind of watch it
if it's on Netflix now.
I've become so normy that like,
I don't really want to,
I just don't want to have to deal
with like shitty websites, now.
It really takes me out of it.
- No. I feel that.
- Yeah.
- I feel that.
- Yeah. I've watched like
the first episode of Trese.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- The Fillipino one.
- It was pretty good. It was pretty good.
- [Joey] Yeah?
- I would need to watch more of it,
but it seemed pretty good so far.
- Okay.
- What's Trese about?
- It's the one that's set in Manila
in the Philippines.
It's like a-
- Yeah, Trese, it's basically,
think of if Ghosts in
the Shell and Blood Sea
had a baby and it was
born in the Philippines.
- Okay.
- That's what that show is.
- Ghost hunter show kind of thing.
- Ghost hunter, like monster hunter show.
- It's pretty badass.
I mean, I really enjoyed
everything I saw from it so far.
You should watch it and
actually form an opinion on it.
- Yeah. The weird thing
about Netflix anime,
or Netflix shows is that like,
you just browse on Netflix
and there's this show,
that you've just never heard of before.
And you're like, has
anyone talks about this?
I don't know. Like, no,
I've literally seen no exposure
for this one show and you
just end up putting it on
and you're like, oh,
that was pretty decent.
- I mean, that's how I
felt about Castlevania.
Right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Connor] Oh, Castlevania.
- When that first came out,
I was like, oh, what is this?
I never saw even Netflix
promoting the show.
And I was like, oh, I'll give it a go.
I liked the games. And I watched it.
It was amazing.
- Yeah.
I heard they might be producing
a spinoff or something.
- Oh really?
- Yeah. 'Cause apparently
the main, that story's over,
but they might be doing a spinoff,
which I really want
because I want more sexy voice acting.
- Yes, please.
- So good. Watch CastlevaniaiIf
you haven't already.
- Yeah.
The only anime I've
been watching recently,
which I highly recommend is a Odd Taxi.
- Yeah. I've been meaning to watch that.
- That's just something that's
just gone under the radar.
And it is probably like,
I think maybe my anime of the season.
I don't know.
- Ooh.
- Oh.
- It's tough. It really,
really was a sleeper hit.
- I can tell you what's
not anime of the season
fucking Wonder Egg Priority.
- Yeah. I know.
- God. I was so sad.
- We'll get on to that, but yeah.
- So, okay, so from Odd
Taxi, I don't know anything,
but I've also been told that
you don't want to know anything
because it spoils it.
- [Joey] Yeah. Yeah.
- From what everyone's told me.
And that's probably why it's having
a hard time getting promoted.
- You have to go into it blind right?
Because, if you tell
people what it's about,
it sounds like one of those shows
that kind of gets ruined a bit
like all spoiled if you tell
them even anything about it.
- Kind of. It's more so like,
it's kind of hard to
tell you what it is about
because it's about a lot of things.
- I assume it's about Taxis.
- Kind of, like the biggest thing,
the reason it's called Odd Taxi is
because the main character
is a taxi driver, I guess.
- Okay.
- But I guess like the hardest
or the easiest way to describe it,
it's kind of like a
Tarantino movie or something,
something along those lines, where-
- Is it like Taxi Driver,
the Scorsese film?
- You said that to me.
And I was like, I'm pretty sure I know
what's going to happen in this thing.
Just off that description alone.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Where I'm like, "Oh, I
bet there's going to be
like a bunch of people
who come in the taxi
and they seem all unrelated.
And then we find out that
everything is all related
and tied together in a neat story.
- [Joey] Right. Right.
- I bet that's what it was.
- Yeah. That's exactly what it's like.
- Right.
- Tarantino.
- Well, I mean, but I mean, that's the,
that's like the easiest
way you can describe it,
because it is kind of
like a Tarantino movie.
And what I love about Odd Taxi is that
it's been so long since
I've just seen an anime
that has just set up its premise,
told it's story and then
just wrapped everything up
in a neat little package.
And, the part of the
reason I think it like
blew up a lot in like the past week is
just 'cause it's ending was
just really fucking good.
It tied everything up.
- It's finished now?
- Yeah. It's finished now.
- How many episodes?
- It's 13 episodes.
And you just, you watch this anime
and it's 13 episodes and that's it.
There's no more.
Everything's tied up.
It's a really, really good ending that-
- How do we milk it for more?
If it's good?
How do we merchandise it?
- I don't know. I dunno.
- Garnt, think about these things.
- I don't know.
- You've got to have an anime
that has a clean ending.
- Yeah. It's just clean.
It's just a clean anime.
- I'm going to watch. I'm sold.
- It's been so long
since I've seen an anime
that's just got a really tight script
to where it sets up
everything it needs to set up.
- A race.
- It gives you the right. Yeah. Exactly.
Exactly, just like a race.
It gives you-
- Just like it. Just like it.
- It gives you the right climax
for everything that is set up
and then it just ends.
And, I'm just like. Damn.
That's just everything I need in the show.
That's what I love about
watching TV shows, and-
- Damn. All right.
- It's been so long
since I've seen a TV show
just end like that.
- So, I got to watch Boys, Odd Taxi,
I was about to say Erased.
Not erased.
- Invincible.
- Invincible. That's it.
So many to watch.
- And apparently I didn't
watch Wonder Egg Priority,
but I heard that it was a mess.
- I watched up to episode 10, I think.
So, I'm only-
- You should probably
just stop where you're at.
- I loved what I saw.
- Yeah.
You should probably stop
where you're at, 'cause.
- Okay. So, what the fuck happened?
- Basically, well, for starters,
well, I don't want to give too much away,
but basically half of the
OVA is a fucking recap,
which already was like a red flag to me.
I was like, we don't need a recap.
- We don't do that here.
- Why do you need a recap in an ending.
- You asked me, man, you fucking asked me.
- Wait a minute, in the 20 minute episode?
- [Connor] 40. It was 40.
- I think it was 40,
45, something like that.
- Okay. So it was-
- It was two episodes.
- About 15 minutes of it was a recap.
It was a really long recap.
At least it felt like a long time to me.
- Well, when they get too
comfortable with recapping shit,
you know, something's going wrong,
and you're like, "Oh, getting
a little too comfortable
with those recaps over there, huh, anime?"
- And then, they just added
like three new elements
to the story that just was
introduced, but never resolved.
So we're like, wait, wait.
So you literally just added this element,
like 20 minutes before the
ending, and then that's it.
- You know, when people
like love a show so much,
they don't wanna admit that it's wrong.
I bet there's people on Twitter that like,
I bet those people on
Twitter that were like,
"Now, now guys, hold on.
They might be onto something here."
- [Joey] Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
- Please, please do something.
Fix what you've done, please.
- And it was just like,
and I just felt so shitty,
because like, again, like the first season
when I watched it, it was amazing. Right?
Like you've watched up until episode 10.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Fucking amazing, right?
- I couldn't wait for it to be concluded.
- Yeah. And, unfortunately,
it wasn't even concluded
with the final episode.
It just left more questions than answers.
And, everyone was just like, "Cool."
- So wait, so wait.
When they didn't conclude it,
did they leave room for a season two?
Or was that just a, "Well, fuck you guys.
This is how it ends."
- I think they tried to
do like a really like,
open-ended like Madoka-esque ending,
except unlike the Madoka
ending, nothing was explained.
So, like you couldn't even
form a theories about what,
was anything there, right?
At least the Madoka ending,
it was kind of like,
all right, we can kind of figure out.
- Fucks your wife.
Leaves. Chat.
- It's like, we can kind of figure out
why it ended like this. Right?
It's a lot of it is like
very like, you know,
a metaphorical and everything.
It's like, okay,
we can kind of figure out
theories of what this might mean.
But with Wonder, they kind of did that,
but they were like no clues for you.
Figure it out. Bye.
- Oh, you like the show? Fuck you.
Fuck you.
- Yeah. It literally was just like, it,
it felt like CloverWorks was just like,
"All right, I give up.
Fuck it. End it. Roll the credits."
- Didn't CloverWorks also
adapt Promised Neverland?
- Promised Neverland season two.
- Ooh. Ooh.
- Yeah, they've been on not a
great streak, unfortunately.
Which is such a shame,
because they always start
off so strong. Right?
Like Promised Neverland
started off really strong.
Wonder Egg started off really strong,
and none of them have been
able to stick the landing.
- Everyone's gonna, anytime
they get anything now,
that's going good.
Everyone's going to be like,
"Guys, don't get excited.
Just wait. Just wait."
- Just wait, just wait, just wait.
- Just wait until the ending happens.
Yeah.
'Cause I was so disappointed
when I heard that.
'Cause I was actually,
I watched up to episode 10
and I really, really was enjoying it.
- Yeah.
- But then I remember thinking, I'm like,
"Ah, it's still setting a plot points
and still exploring
characters, 10 episodes in.
It's got to end in three episodes.
That's not a lot of time there.
- Yeah. It definitely was built.
I feel for a 24 episode,
like a two core series,
but I feel like they just
weren't given the opportunity to.
- I just also can't believe
what they did to Promised
Neverland season two.
So, if you don't know,
Promised Neverland was an amazing show.
One of the best selling manga, right?
- Yeah.
- It was like the top five, yeah.
- It was four, right?
- It sold more than My Hero Academia.
- Yeah. It's like the fourth
top five best selling manga
of all time.
The first season was amazing
if you haven't watched it.
- The manga is fantastic.
- And then, instead of just
like doing what they were doing,
they're like, "Now, hold on guys.
What if we just do something else?"
- No, they were literally like,
"All right. So we just
finished the current arc,
how many chapters do we have left?
Like 150?
How many episodes do we have left? Three.
All right.
Skip about 120 episodes and
just go straight to the end."
- Yeah. That's-
- That's literally what they did.
- They fucked the show up completely.
- And then, the final
episode was literally
a PowerPoint presentation.
- And then, and you know
how it is, you know,
there's like when you
get a bad adaptation,
there's a cool-down period where,
there's not a set rule, but
it's like a societal rule
where you can't make a remake
now within the next 10 years.
So, it's 10 years now,
we're not going to get a
good Promised Neverland.
- [Joey] No.
- Adaptation until someone is like,
"Wow, dust this off."
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I mean look at this.
I mean, they tried to
recover with the live action.
But, that was also horrible.
- There's a live action?
- It was Korean though. Right?
- No. It was Japanese.
- It was Japanese? I saw the poster.
It looked like a porno film.
Like I dunno why.
It didn't look good.
- I think the most live
action anime adaptations
do look like a porno film.
- I think porno parodies actually
kind of look better, sometimes.
- Japanese like movie posters
also look like Japanese porn posters.
- It's the same production quality.
- They literally, it's really bizarre.
- Yeah. I've seen like AX cosplay shoots
that look better than
some of these posters.
You know?
- Yeah.
- Like, it's wild seeing like just
how they look sometimes.
Like I remember the Full Metal Alchemist,
like live action one.
- I still haven't seen that movie.
And I fucking refuse to,
because I saw the trailer.
I'm like, if someone
with like, like 500 subs,
uploaded this as like a
April Fool's parody movie,
I would believe it.
Like it was that bad.
The costumes were horrible looking.
Like fucking Ed would
look like a crack addict.
Like with his like hair.
It's just like all over the place.
I'm like, no, don't do that.
Why would you massacre my boy like that?
It looked so bad?
Oh God.
- I can't get over how they
all look like porn videos.
I'm just like-
- They actually do.
- Dead ass, I've seen
some like porn parodies
of anime that looked better than
some live action animated films.
- I just had this thought the other day,
I'm like, you know, put on a JAV.
And I was like, how come I-
- Just casually?
- Just casually post some JAV.
- I was on the train, put some JAV.
I thought, huh?
How come I've never seen one above 640 P?
- Right?
- Never.
I've never seen a JAV.
- I think it's just cause they
go straight to DVD. Right?
- Yeah.
- Probably.
- The motherfuckers ain't
got 1080P lying around?
Like, I just thought
about it and I'm like-
- It's because the ones that are 1080P
are hidden behind a paywall.
- Yeah.
But, surely someone's
pirating them. Right?
- [Joey] Oh yeah. Of course.
- I was sitting there and I'm
like these, these posters.
They're like movie posters,
amazing immaculate,
immaculate posters.
And every single time,
I'm fighting for my life
to find 720P.
I'll be lucky if I can find it.
And, I thought what's up with that.
Why is it only?
I don't know.
- [Joey] Maybe-
- I cannot tell, you know,
I don't even have an inkling
of what, what year JAVs,
because you know for those
of you who don't know
JAV is the Japanese porn.
I have no idea what year these were made.
I don't even have an idea
of when they were made.
You know, you go on the American porn,
they're in fucking 8K.
What's going on?
What's going on Japan?
- I don't think anyone's looking for
like eight K pixelation of dick, you know?
- No. No.
- It's still pixelate
at the end of the day.
- It's not that I need it.
I just think the technology
is available. You know?
I know they can get these cameras.
Why aren't they?
- Or, maybe what it is is that
the actual JAV is in like 4k,
but then it's the piraters who are like,
I'll just download the HD version.
- No way.
I refuse to believe there's not,
for some reason I've never seen it.
Have you ever seen it?
I've never seen it.
- What, 1080P JAV?
Yeah, I've seen it again.
- Where?
- Again, it's hidden behind a pay wall.
- Oh, my God.
I'm like tell me your sources.
That was just a thought
I was thinking, sorry.
Because we got off, we were
talking about the movie.
I was just-
- I mean, I'm sure it's out there
somewhere deep down in the web,
but like, can I be bothered
to look for it? No.
- No. That's me too.
I don't wanna spend
more than five minutes.
- [Joey] No.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Speaking of things I've been watching.
- Okay.
- Yeah?
- It's not a TV show
or a movie or an anime.
- Ooh. Okay.
- I was watching a particular livestream.
- Oh God.
- Ah.
- Yes.
- Okay.
- I know where we're
going and we shouldn't.
- Women always say men
don't have feelings.
Well, I definitely had feelings
when I was watching a Coco's
Graduation livestream.
- Dude, that was fucking insane.
- That was nuts.
I think I saw like on the news that
I think it was like,
oh, like internet news.
I mean, not the TV news.
I saw on the internet news that
I think that ended up being,
I think it's the seventh highest
livestream of all time.
- Livestream of all time.
- Yeah. I saw that as well.
She, I think she capped at 480,000 people
watching her live,
- Yeah. During the concert
bit, she was like 480,000.
I was kind of wondering if
he was going to break 500K.
- I was like, come on, you can do it.
- Half a mil.
- You can do it, simps. Come on.
I believe in you.
- It was nuts,
because I was watching that live
and there's some parts,
the chat was going so fast
that it wasn't literally
lagging the stream.
- Yeah, I saw. I saw.
- Yeah. It was crazy.
- Just occasionally popping in
and just seeing what was going on.
- Yeah.
- I mean, I didn't care much about like
the whole like idle side of things.
'Cause I've never really
cared about the whole,
whole live idle side of things
or whatever, but like yeah,
there were parts where I was just like
getting a little emotional here.
- Honestly, honestly, same.
Because I couldn't watch it live,
because we were doing
something at the time.
- Yeah.
- but I watched like the
recording afterwards.
- Yeah.
- And honestly it was like, I'm,
as I've said of what
I watched less VTubers
now than I did last year.
But man, it was getting
emotional at some points.
- Yeah. Yeah.
Holy Shit.
'Cause I honestly think
this is an end of an era
for Hololive because I think
Hololive owes cocoa so fucking much.
Right?
- Yeah. Absolutely.
- Because she is basically the sole reason
why hololive is as big internationally.
She's basically the reason
why Hololive English exists.
Right?
- Yeah, exactly.
- And I feel like to me,
it was like the end of an era for Hololive
because you know,
she's done so much for the company
and now she's just not there anymore.
And you know,
I feel like she did move
out of her own accord,
which is happy that no big,
like controversy happened
to make her move.
- It's fully respectable
that she was just like,
"I kind of just don't
want to be hear anymore
for whatever reason.
See you later," kind of thing.
- Yeah.
Which would just made it
even more bitter sweet.
'Cause I'm happy that
she made the decision
to move on and do whatever
she wants to do now.
But, you know, it is-
- And she went out with a fucking bang.
- Holy Shit.
- Like I saw those super chats, bro.
I don't want to think about how much money
she made from that.
- If you're not enjoying
it, go out on top, right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And then also,
I mean she clearly enjoys
doing other stuff on the side.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- So, why not, right?
Like you can bring a massive
audience over with you.
- [Garnt] Yeah. Yeah.
- So, if you do a show like that,
like people of course go check
out what you're doing next.
So it was a brilliant idea as well.
- Yeah. Yeah, exactly.
- 'Cause I mean, I think honestly,
Coco in terms of just like looking
at each talent and as content creators,
I do think she is genuinely
one of the most talented content creators
in Hololive.
And, that's just, and
I mean, if she wasn't,
then she wouldn't have had the success
that she did internationally, I think.
- Also.
Can I say massive brain
idea that she prerecorded
like the interview sections and
put English subtitles on it?
- Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
- I was like, that is so gigabrain.
- Because I was like, wait, how are they?
How are they subtitling that fast?
I was like whoa is that just like a track?
- This subtitler is a mad man.
- Yeah. The JoJo event
panel people are like,
"How are they doing this?
This is impossible.
- At first, I just thought that I was like
some fucking light speed translator
but I go, (Garnt makes computer sound)
He's like, "I've got
this boys. I got this."
- Yeah. I was like that's so gigabrain,
because she clearly knows
how like Eric and her
international fan base was just
as big as a Japanese fan base.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- So it's like why not get both of them
in at the same time?
- Yeah.
- So gigabrain.
- I mean, I feel like that's
why the live stream was partly
how it broke so many records. Right?
It's just because it wasn't
just the Japanese audience watching.
I mean, it, wasn't only just gonna be
a Japanese audience watching it anyway,
but there was always going to
be a big part of the audience.
They just didn't get what was going on.
And, I was like, should I cry now?
Is it always-
- Like, am I crying now?
Am I crying?
Are you crying?
- Is it the goodbye time? No.
- Right now? Right now?
- Right now it's oh. Okay.
But, no.
Thanks to the subtitles,
everyone can get involved in it.
So, it was just like a fivehead move.
- Yeah. Absolutely.
- Yeah. And, it's-
- It's sad.
- What did you think of it Connor?
- I didn't really watch it.
I mean, I was watching it occasionally.
I was like, "Wow, this is pretty cool."
It was all right.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I mean, again, like
I've mentioned before,
I don't really like, I'm
not like a massive simp
of any of them.
I don't know if that's a derogatory term.
- Banned on Twitch.
- I don't particularly
like watch a lot of them.
I know people are like,
"Well, you collab with them."
Yeah. It's different though.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- So I, you know, to me
it was like, all right.
I mean, it was cool.
Like it was an epic show from what I saw.
- [Joey] Yeah it was.
- Epic, sorry.
I can't say that word
without being sarcastic.
- Epic.
- It was clearly just
an amazing production.
Props to the team.
I mean, if you're going to go out,
why not fucking do it like that? You know?
Hell yeah.
- [Joey] Fucking out.
- 'Cause it's like, I feel like, wait,
what was I going to say again?
I feel like they did
really put on a good show
and it was going out with a bang.
And, if there was a way that
she was going to go out,
this was the best way to go out.
- Yeah.
- I completely agree with her creatively.
And, I hope the best for
her future endeavors,
because I would choose the same thing.
I would choose to go with a bang
rather than just like fizzle out.
- Fizzle out. Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. Absolutely.
- Especially if you're not
happy with what you're doing.
Right? If it's inevitable
that it's going to happen.
So yeah, it was the right move, I think.
- It just really now
puts into perspective.
I'm just like who who's the
next one that's going to go?
If there is going to be
another one that's going to go-
- It's an interesting thing
because I feel that because
it was so new and so fresh,
the idea of people are gonna leave.
It was so odd. Right?
But I guess they,
you can't always repeat
it with people joining.
Right?
It's going to get to a point
where there's going to be as
many people leaving as it was joining.
- I do.
- There has to be.
- That's the thing. Right.
It's like, I do wonder
'cause Coco was the first Hololive talent
to leave Hololive on
her own accord, right?
Like, I'm just thinking like, I'm sure.
- I guess of we know, right?
- Yeah. That we know of.
- That we know of.
- But like, I'm sure like her announcing
that she was going to leave
probably planted in some
of other talent's heads
had to be like, "Oh,-"
- You can do that?
- You can leave?
- You can just quit?
- Yeah.
- Well yeah, I think, the
most interesting thing
for me personally about VTubers
it's like the politics of it all.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah.
- It seems like there
is like a lot of rules.
- Especially on the JP side
- [Garnt] Yeah. Yeah.
- And it's just really
entertaining watching it
because everyone's like,
"No, you can't turn left.
You have to turn right."
- [Joey] Yeah.
- You know, and everyone's
like freaking out.
And it's really, I don't know-
- It's like thousands of
people back seating you, right?
- It's very fun watching
this kind of stuff,
you know, and the rules
and all the politics.
It's very, it's like, you know,
it's like people turn anime
into a Game of Thrones
sometimes, these Vtubers
and it's heller exciting.
I love watching it.
I'm like a spectator, you know.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- In that sense.
And I think that this, yeah,
this does ask the question of,
is this going to be a normal thing?
How will it be dealt with?
What impact will this have
on VTubing as a whole?
Who knows?
I'm going to be watching on the sidelines
having a great time.
- Because recently there's been a couple
of like bigger Nijisanji VTubers
as well that are like
left on their own accord.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- And it's like, I feel
it's like slowly starting
to become a thing of like,
just especially the bigger creators
kind of realizing that,
"Oh, if I stay in, you know,
this kind of like agency,
then I'm kind of limited
to what I can do."
- You are. You can only
be a Vtuber, right?
- And, it's only up until
they get to a certain point
that they realize like,
"Oh, if I just leave,
I have so many more
opportunities that I can try out
for myself without
being like, restricted."
- It's the question, right?
- It's like a Catch 22. Right?
- Yeah.
- Because I feel like, you know,
without saying anything too
private, like, you know,
I feel like Coco was one of the few
who had established yourself
like outside, you know?
And I feel like, especially
with how big she is,
she can do whatever the
hell she wants, you know?
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And be able to establish herself.
But, I feel like with,
especially with some Hololive VTubers,
they're only known for
being Hololive VTubers.
- Sure. Sure
- Right?
And it's like a catch 22
because they could leave
whenever they want.
But, if they leave,
what would they be saying goodbye to?
You know, they'd basically
have to like build themselves
up from the ground up again.
- Yeah.
- And with the VTubing
scene being how it is,
they can't really build up their other,
any other kind of thing that
they do outside of Hololive.
Right? Because that's the-
- They kind of just be
like typecasted, right?
- It's like, you know,
it's the secrecy behind the Vtubing,
and there is a reason for it.
But, at the same time,
if there is a VTuber,
who does want to talk
about their other lives
then they just can't with
the platform they have.
And, they're just-
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Going to be known
as this Hololive VTuber
rather than anything else they
may potentially want to be.
- Sure. Sure.
- Which is why, if I think
if we saw someone leave
a Vtuber Agency to become another VTuber,
I'd feel like that's like the wrong idea,
- Yeah.
- But the whole point
is to expand, you know?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And do something else.
Otherwise, why did you leave?
- You just made it harder
on yourself. Right?
- Right. Right. And also like, you know,
obviously Hololive is big
and there's, you know,
there's other agencies and this is,
I mean, God, there's fucking so many now.
- [Joey] Yeah.
What I find it interesting now
as a content creator is that,
you know, in YouTube and Twitch,
there's like, there's hierarchies,
right, of like your size.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Right? And like with
YouTube and Twitch where you,
you're kind of on your own,
you kind of just do your own thing.
You do what you want. If
you're with an agency,
there's kind of expectations
of you to perform
or do anything. Right?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And so, you know, when
you start bringing in talent
and you keep bringing in talent,
what happens when you have too much,
too many people and the
market is oversaturated,
and it's partially your agency. Right?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- So what if you have too many VTubers,
and maybe y'all some of the
Vtubers aren't doing too well,
struggling a little bit.
How do you handle that?
Like, what do you do?
Do you like, just leave it?
- [Joey] You just, yeah.
- 'Cause that's where I'm
like interested in seeing
how they handle that.
'Cause that'll really show
what their mindset is-
- [Joey] Right.
- On how to handle situations.
- Well because, I think
currently Hololive now has
like less than 30, no, around 30 I'd say.
- Of all? No. There's
more than that, right?
- Well, yeah.
Actually if you include EN and IN and IDN
there's a whole list-
- And, there's a whole list
of languages in the future.
- Yeah.
- Let's say, yeah okay, let's guess like,
probably around like
less than 50, I reckon,
which is still a lot,
but then you have agencies like Nijisanji
that have literally hundreds of VTubers.
- Right. Right.
And like, you know, do you,
if you're an agency where
you're like, okay, you know,
if we want to keep bringing in new talent,
we've got to hire more staff.
We can't afford to, to it,
'cause not everyone's
pulling in the same numbers.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Not everyone can be the
number one, obviously.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- What do you do?
Do you start cutting off talent?
If so, how does that look publicly?
Right?
- Right. I mean, I feel like
that's a lose, lose, right?
'Cause you can't just cut off
talent because no matter what,
if you cut talent off the fact,
their fan base is gonna
fucking make a lot of noise
- [Connor] Right.
- And you don't come
out looking good at all.
- No.
- And I guess, I dunno,
it's, it's interesting,
but I don't think-
- There's just so many problems,
and the challenges that
I think will arise,
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Because we haven't seen them yet
because it's been so new.
But I think down the line,
we're gonna be coming into these things
and I'm just interested to see
how the fan bases will handle
all these things coming up
because they're going
to happen at some point.
- Sure. Yeah.
- I mean, right now
with the VTubing scene,
it's kind of like the wild west.
- [Connor] Yeah. It is. Yeah.
- Because it's the new thing.
And it's just starting
to establish itself now.
Like it's, it's only
getting, it's only getting
to the point now where,
you know, we, we had the
massive explosion in 2020,
and now we're kind of seeing
what the YouTube scene,
VTubing scene, sorry,
is going to be really
like in 2021 and above
because you know, right now Coco leaving,
that's a massive creator on the platform.
And arguably she,
for the longest time, she
was the face of Hololive.
- Yeah.
- Especially like early 2020, she was-
- Internationally especially.
- Yeah. Internationally, she was the face.
And now it's kind of like,
it's becoming a new kind of scene now.
So, it's interesting.
It's going to be interesting
to see how the scene develops.
- There's just so many
interesting things that are,
that happen and challenges
that will come up
in that kind of a space
as opposed to normal YouTubing and Twitch.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- That, I just, cause
we live this job, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- So I'm just fascinated
by how a company would deal
or how it would tackle
some of those challenges.
- It's going to be interesting to see
who they'll sideline, right? Yeah.
- Yeah. I don't know. That's
what I find most interesting
about it. - [Joey] Yeah.
- It's you know,
I just love seeing the scene.
It's such an interest, it's like,
this is the first time
we've probably God knows
when we can see this again,
where a whole kind of genre
has just popped up-
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Very quickly and explodes
and is very self-contained
because normally everything's-
- Is it self-contained?
- I think it's the most
self-contained we've seen
out of any genre on online.
- Oh, I think Hololive
is obviously definitely
very self-contained by,
you know, by design,
but I feel like VTubing as
a whole is now kind of like,
especially with the amount of VTubers
that have popped up on Twitch
and every other streaming platform.
- Yeah. Now, it's not so much, but-
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I guess it was interesting at the time.
I think, it's everyone's
just doing everything now,
but yeah.
- I think it's still
self-contained in a sense
because like, yeah, you have
a lot more like individual
VTubers now doing things
with other individual
VTubers and you know,
Vtubers, and agencies and stuff like that.
But at the end of the day, if you yourself
also aren't a Vtuber,
it's very difficult to do anything
with those kinds of people.
More difficult than I'd say, you know,
like if I wanted to collab
with like another YouTuber.
- I don't know.
I think it's just a humor thing, really.
If you have the same
kind of content-ish aimed
at the same audience kind of
thing, it's doable, I think.
I don't know. Yeah.
- I feel like VTubing is just
obviously the trends now,
but I feel like if
anything, if you're just,
if you want to start off
streaming or something
or just you're a new content creator,
then just by being a VTuber,
you're more likely to get
noticed than just by like
being a normal on-camera streamer.
- Sure. Sure.
- Unfortunately, I don't know why that is.
It just is now.
- People like anime, Bro.
That's just how it is, isn't it?
- Yeah. People just want
to see anime girls and boys, apparently.
They just hate the real people.
- I don't know.
Is there a big male Vtuber?
I don't think we've seen
any big one, though?
- Actually the, the biggest
Vtuber in Nigisangi is a guy.
- Is it really?
- Yeah. There's this guy called Kuzuha
who I think has like almost 900K subs.
- Oh shit. Really?
- Yeah. And he was really
interesting as well
because he was actually
scouted by Nijisanji,
because he was originally
an individual Vtuber.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Who gained so much of a
massive and dedicated fan base
that he got picked up by Nijisanji.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And, now he's the
biggest Nijisanji streamer.
And, he's essentially the
biggest male streamer.
- I wonder why I'm never getting
recommended clips of him.
- 'Cause he's very Japanese.
- I get recommended
Japanese clips all the time.
I'm like, I don't watch this, but-
- [Joey] Yeah.
- stop shoving the bandwidth.
- I mean, he's really fun.
Like I watched a couple of his streams,
and he's super fun to watch,
but it's just really
interesting how he managed
to stand on top of a very female oriented
like agency, right?.
- Yeah. Yeah, because that is interesting.
I don't think we in English,
I don't think there's a big male VTuber.
- Not really.
- Which is weird to think because most
of the big streamers are male.
I mean, streaming is like right now,
at least the male
dominated market where you,
'cause you got like Valkyrae and Pokimane
up there in the top 10.
But, everyone else I think is male.
- Yeah.
- [Connor] It's messed up.
- But like with VTubers pretty much,
I think 90% of the big VTubers are female.
Right now, at least.
- Yeah, definitely. I mean-
- I wonder why do you think that is?
Like, just throwing ideas out there. Like.
- Wifus.
- Yeah. I think literally wifus. Yeah.
- People want to watch
cute girls than cute boys.
Right?
That's just how it is. Unfortunately.
- You think so?
I don't know.
I feel like it's too easy
to say that that's like,
I don't know.
There's gotta be a reason.
Maybe, I've never like I've watched.
because sometimes I'll
just click the Vtuber tag
on Twitch and I'll browse through,
and you know, and I haven't
really seen many guys
in there that I'm like,
oh yeah, it's not like super
naturally entertaining.
I don't know. It's tough.
- Because what makes this might be getting
into a different topic,
but what does make a popular streamer?
Because-
- Maybe, you know, maybe.
Yeah. It's tough.
- 'Cause like, what is the
audience for male streamers?
Is it still mostly males or-
- I don't know. I feel I
don't know if Twitch tells me.
- It depends on the contents, right?
- I have a pretty healthy
balance, I think. Both.
- Can you even look that up on Twitch.
- Fuck if I know.
I mean, you probably can.
- I know you can on YouTube, but like-
Oh, you can?
I'll check later and we'll
put it on the screen.
- But it is weird now
that I think about it
why there are so few
big, bigger male Vtubers
compared to the females.
- I don't want to say like the meme,
but is it, is it maybe the fact
that if you're a, you know,
you would just be a normal male streamer,
if you were good at it.
Is there benefits to
being a VTuber as a male
over just doing, showing
your face if you can?
- I don't know actually.
It's really strange, because like, I feel,
I feel actually like internationally,
this idea of like VTubers
has very much been created
and established through
Hololive where like, you know,
but like at the end of the day,
you have to realize that
Hololive is actually
the weirder one because they're
more of like an idol agency.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Whereas like Nijisanji
VTubers and like Vshojo
or like even like the
individual VTubers, right.
They're not idols.
They're just streamers.
- I wonder if it's the case of like,
people like, this is gonna to sound bad,
but I think this is true.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I think guys want to watch a guy
who they think is their bro.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- They think it's that mate.
They feel like they can
joke with, you know,
it's and their humor.
And, I think that guys
want to watch girls,
they're the ideal of their
girl that they want to watch.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- You think almost, right?
- I agree with that.
- And I think that works
perfectly with Vtubing,
'cause you can give the
character, you want to play it,
but you can also put a nice,
healthy injection of personality.
I wonder if that doesn't
quite work with guys,
but then again, I guess that's
the question of what's the,
if you're a male, Vtuber,
watch your target demo.
Are you trying to be the sexy VTuber?
Because I've seen those guys
who are trying to be the sexy Vtuber,
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And I cringe internally, and a lot-
- [Joey] 'cause I think-
- They do their voice like "Yeah. Okay.
I'm a male Vtuber."
Oh, sorry.
- Yeah. 'Cause I feel like with
a lot of male VTubers I've seen-
- I'm going to get shit for doing that.
Fuck my life.
- No. I've got, I think
that's a legit point.
'Cause I think like with a
lot of male VTubers I see.
And, it's kind of like they
trying to take the Hololive
kind of a model and flip it
and gender it and gender flip it, right?
- Except I don't think it works at all.
- Yeah. And I think at the end of the day,
a lot of male streamers
that are big have like
an equal amount of male to female viewers,
if not, maybe more so male.
- Which is really interesting. Right.
Because again, when I
was looking up on Kuzuha,
the top streamer for Nijisanji.
His audience is 95% like female.
- Yeah.
- That makes sense.
- [Joey] But, it's really weird.
- Also in Japan that is normally like
they're very much more
willing to buy into that.
- Yeah.
- But, what's really weird
is that his personality
does not match that demographic.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- His personality is a
little more like gruff
and just like straight to the point.
He's really like foul mouthed.
- Well, that's popular in Japan, though.
I know that as well.
- It is popular in Japan.
But, like you would think
that the standard formula
to get a female audience, right.
Is like, as you said,
like the very like, ah,
like type of guys. Right?
- But then I don't think that is.
I think when you try to
be sexy, you're not sexy.
- [Joey] Right. Right.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And also, you know-
- Especially when you're an avatar.
- That's what for me,
maybe because I'm older.
Right?
When I see a guy who's
using an anime avatar
and he's doing this like edging voice
where like, (Connor breathes deeply)
I'm like, bro,
like literally just
imagine a guy in his room
in front of like a Dell
monitor going, "Oh yeah. Oh."
- In front of his poor Yeti.
- Yeah. It's like, to me,
it's like, I don't want that.
You know?
- Yeah.
- I'm not shitting on anybody, you know,
I'm not saying they are out there,
but I have seen some that have done it
and I'm just like, Oh, for fuck's sake.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nah, I know what they're doing. Yeah.
- I think there just hasn't,
it's hard because I think if
you're the type of personality
that would need to kill it
as a male VTuber is
also the kind of person
who wouldn't give a fuck
about showing their face.
At least I think so.
- I feel like if anything,
unlike being a female VTuber,
but being a male VTuber
actually makes it harder
for you to get noticed.
- [Connor] Yeah, definitely.
- Ah. Definitely. Yeah.
- Yeah, which I've never
really thought until now.
- It's hard, because I'm
sure there's gonna be tons
of male VTubers out there who are like,
"You are totally wrong,"
but it's like, well I think we come from
a perspective of just
general entertainment
and YouTube and then live streaming.
And we have these kind of, I feel like
we've been doing this
for a very long time-
- Yeah.
and we have kind of, we know what kind
of personalities work in certain areas.
So, I'm not thinking about it.
I feel like when you're in the community,
you're almost to regurgitative
of ideas around you.
you know, you kind of see, you
copy everything around you.
'Cause that's what people do. Right?
You don't do, you don't
try and stand out, but-
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Yeah. I don't know.
It's tough because I love-
- [Joey] It's fascinating.
- Yeah. It's so interesting.
'Cause that's the thing is that
I feel like no one's
really figured it out yet
in English at least.
I'm sure someone's going
to come and be like,
"No, well what about this guy?"
Like, if they had done it-
- We don't know every Vtuber.
- If they'd of done it, if
they've killed it really,
they'll probably be high up. You know?
- Yeah.
- If they're not right
now, they will be soon.
I'll eat my words. You know what I mean?
- The fact that we can't immediately
say a name is I think telling.
- That's like super big.
You know I'm talking about like-
- Yeah, because I obviously
do know male Vtubers
are out there.
- Yeah. Yeah. Same.
- But none of them are pulling
in like the numbers close to-
- Yeah, none of them are
pulling in the numbers
that female Vtubers are or anywhere close
from what I've seen.
- [Connor] No. No.
- I mean all the big
agencies, all the big groups,
the main focus is the female VTubers.
And like the male VTubers, there are like,
for example Holo Stars,
but that always seems like tacked on.
- [Joey] Yeah. Yeah.
- Holo Stars doesn't really pull
in that much compared to the girls.
- It really doesn't. It really doesn't.
- Yeah. Yeah. It really
doesn't, unfortunately
for whatever reason.
- I feel it's because again,
like that's on Hololive and
not promoting Holo Stars
as much as Hololive.
- I also just think that
like they don't know.
Like, it's so difficult.
I think it is genuinely very difficult
to get the right personalities.
- It's also difficult
to like really nail down
like a target demographic,
especially if you're a guy like,
because you do have so many avenues,
unlike a lot of female Vtubers
where it's like you'll target
demographic is very obvious.
- Yeah. I also want to
say that I don't, I'm not,
we're not trying to sit here and argue
that it's easy to be a female Vtuber.
I think it's just like,
I don't think the right
personality has like
kind of figured it out yet.
I think it's the same, but
it's, you know, it's just-
- Yeah. I think the important thing is
that you can't just take what works
for a female VTuber,
but put it in the male avatar.
- 100%. 100%.
- And, expect it to
produce the same results.
I think it is a very different field
and there is a discussion there about why.
You know, it's the same with
female streamers as well.
There's a reason I think that, you know,
a lot of the top streamers
right now are males.
You know, that's just the
way things are right now.
And I think it's kind of
the reverse for VTubers,
if anything.
- Yeah.
- Never really thought about it until now.
- Yeah. It's fascinating.
- Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
- That's what I mean.
This is what, the stuff that I wake up
in middle of the night
thinking about. You know?
- In a cold sweat.
- But, this is why.
This is why, like again,
like I don't really watch,
I'm not like an avid watcher of anyone.
I just kind of like watch
channels here and there
and watch like, I'll go on Twitch,
And I've watched a lot of
the small VTubers on Twitch.
I'll just flick between them
at night, watch five minutes.
All Right. I've seen enough.
Watch five minutes.
All right. I've seen enough.
Just kind of like seeing what
everyone's doing, you know?
I'm just trying to find
something out there
that's really interesting.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
And again, I think
because the scene is so,
so young right now,
like it's got all of these
really interesting problems
that like haven't been figured out yet.
Whereas YouTube and Twitch
had been gamified to death.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Like we can probably tell you
who's going to be good
and who isn't and who's gonna
be able to figure stuff out.
You know what I mean?
Like it's, again, it's super interesting.
And, I find it so fascinating,
and I love, since I'm obsessed
with YouTube obsessed with Twitch.
I love everything about content creation
and the fact that I get to experience
something brand new kind
of pop up and get to like,
watch it unfold is like the
most fun I've had in forever.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Because I just like YouTube man.
- Yeah. That's why I've
just been really enjoying
like kind of watching around
all these different kinds
of Vtubers.
- [Connor] Yeah. It's fun.
- 'Cause it's just like,
it's just, 'cause, you know,
for the longest time I always just thought
VTubing equals Hololive.
When, now I know that is
completely not the case.
There's so many variants out there
that are just completely
different to a Hololive story.
- Yeah. When I find a
guy who I think is small
and is about to blow
up and kill it, VTuber,
I'll write it down.
I'll let you know.
I'll be like I told you so.
- Promote it.
- But, right now, I don't
think there's anyone
who's kind of got the right formula
that's going to take off.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Yeah. Everyone's still
trying to figure out
their own thing right now.
- I think so. I think
everyone's kind of scrambling.
Just going to see what's going to work.
- I mean, I feel like
the male VTubing scenes,
they were waiting for
that first big creator
that everyone's going to follow,
because it only takes one, right?
- Yeah. The Ninja of Male Vtubers.
I've not seeing enough movement.
- Yeah, 'cause like Hololive figured out
the perfect formula for female
VTubers and everyone like.
- Now that they're like, write that down,
do it again and in the more languages.
- And then it worked and now
VTubing's massive for females.
And then I feel like it's going
to take that first massive male creator
on the same level as Hololive
or like other big female creators,
that's going to be like, okay,
this is what works,
everyone copy this guy.
- I mean, that's how it always is, right?
- [Garnt] That's how it always is.
- This is what works. Copy it.
But then again, that's why I feel like
it's not really going anywhere right now
just because everyone's
just copying everyone
who isn't seeing massive success.
- Yeah.
So, it's interesting. Again.
- It's that meme of like
the artists are giving $50
to the same artist just
going around in circles.
- So I mean, that's what Twitch is.
Like it's,
everyone's iterating on
each other and copying
and that's how it is.
And, that's how it's always kind of been.
- There's always one person who's like,
how about I don't that.
- Yeah. Someone always has that one idea
that just changes the system.
- Yeah.
But then, eventually
that original person will
just set a trend and then that
trend will become the norm.
- Yeah.
- And then you build on that trend
and you keep building on that trend.
- And then, the new system is created.
- Yeah. It's just like
the clickbait law, right?
Like, clickbait evolves on YouTube
because then there's this
like anti-clickbait meta
that I always see pop up
that eventually becomes
the clickbait itself.
- [Connor] True, true.
- Yeah.
- Like I remember like ages
ago before, like before,
like ProZD popularized the,
"Hey, I don't give a
shit about clickbait,"
It's just going to be my face,
and just like a very basic title.
- Yeah.
- With like no caps or whatever.
And then that just became,
that became a whole
genre in and of itself.
- Yeah, because a video with no clickbait
and a shit ton of views is clickbait.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Because, you're curious,
how did this get viewed?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- This has to something's
going on here, right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- If you saw like, you know, like a video
that had one of those like
Indian Facebook posts,
levels of editing that
had like 10 million views,
you'd click on that shit.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Because you're like, how the fuck does
this have 10 million views?
- [Joey] Yeah, absolutely.
- And then they have the top place.
- That reminds me of the
shit you were showing me
like last Thursday.
- Yeah.
I was sharing Garnt,
have you seen Dhar Mann?
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I was showing Garnt Dhar Mann, and also-
- Oh my fucking God. What?
I don't get it. I don't get it.
How has this got so many views?
- Garnt isn't into the YouTube desire.
So there's a channel called Dhar Mann.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I don't even know how to
describe it. What is he?
He does these and he, I swear.
It's so popular now.
Everyone knows about it.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- He does these videos where
it's basically like a message,
like, like-
- It's like motivational speech, right?
- There'll be one where it's
like gold digger gets exposed-
- [Joey] Yeah.
or actor quits, because
he got hate comment.
Basically be like, alright,
this guy gets a hate comment online.
And then Dhar Mann comes in with a piece
of motivational advice
that flips it on its head
and the bullies feel like shit.
And the guy who was being bullied,
gets a Lamborghini, succeeds in life.
And it's always that.
Like the most stereotypical,
man gets bullied or
someone does bad thing,
Gets the comeuppance for the bad thing.
And the person who got
did wrong gets done right.
That's always how it is.
- Like, his videos just
hit in like the perfect
or just-
- It's literally Facebook videos.
- Not the perfect, I mean
it is Facebook videos,
but it's even, it hits
that uncanny valley, right?
- [Connor] Right.
- Yes.
- Where it's just so weird to watch
one of these videos and just think
it's the most like bare bones message
that you can present in the video. Right?
And the way, the way I,
the way I thought of it,
watching these videos
that were getting like
tens of millions of views, by the way.
It's, like a R slash
that rarely happens post-
- [Connor] Yeah.
- In every video,
because every video ends with
and then everyone claps.
- Yeah.
- You know, that's-
- What was the dude again
on Facebook Prince Ea?
- [Connor] Prince Ea.
- Yeah. Prince Ea.
Like he kind of did like a similar thing.
(indistinct)
thing where he'd do like
these like beat poetry,
like too deep for you like life lessons.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And, I'm just like,
no one lives like this.
- And then he did like
videos where he's like,
depression is just
sadness. Stop being sad.
He did like videos like that.
- Yeah. He was like, depression
is like this TV remote.
It comes. Then it goes.
- Yeah.
- It comes, then it goes.
- You should turn it off.
- Yeah.
It's just terrible. And then
yeah and I showed Garnt.
I'm like, "Yeah, this guy gets
like 30 million views a
video and he uploads daily.
- Yeah.
- Which like respect to
him and his production crew
because the videos are
like a very well shot.
- Oh yeah. They're very well presented.
It should be because he's
probably making $50 million a year.
- Yeah.
- And, rather low.
- Yeah, and you got like
different, you know,
you've got so many different actors
playing these parts as well.
So you've got like a proper crew
pumping these videos out.
And, I just think like, you know,
it's so weird
because there's so like
there's so few times
where I watch a video
and I watch a trend on YouTube
and I'm just like, "I don't get it.
I don't get it."
Like, how is this doing this well?
Because sometimes you see
a video and you're like,
"Okay, this isn't my type of content,
but I can see why it's doing well."
- Yeah.
- But then, Connor shows me this,
and it's like the hottest trend right now
getting fucking blowing
everyone out in terms of views.
- Yeah.
- And I'm just like, "How?"
- I don't know. I mean, that's
also just really funny, but-
- I mean, I think it
definitely also helps,
the fact that there are a
lot of YouTubers out there,
like poking the shit out of it.
- Oh yeah.
There's so many views
that are just mocking it.
- Yeah. So, like that in and of itself is
just free promotion, right?
- [Connor] It's just so-
- And, I guarantee there's lots of people
like hate watching this shit.
- It's so preachy that you
can't help but watch it
and think fucking hell, like.
- I'm like, "It ain't that deep, bro.
It really ain't that deep."
- It's like I've fucking
seen Disney movies,
less preachy or cheesy.
- [Connor] Yeah. Right? Right?
- Right? Like it's, it's fascinating.
I found it like fascinating
seeing that this was the hot thing
that's going on right now.
- And I also showed him Arcade Craniacs,
if you don't know what that is?
Do you know what that is?
- No. What's that?
- It's the guys who do the 3:00 AM
Among Us a BTS meal video.
- What?
- I told him. It's honestly impossible.
- It's not like a real video.
- Well, the point is is that
they're basically this channel,
that parodies kid videos,
the 3:00 AM videos for literal
like five-year-olds
but including like adult
jokes that kids wouldn't get,
but also mocking and parodying the style.
It's really, like it's the
most internet humor thing
I've ever watched,
and it's so funny.
- [Joey] Okay.
- It's so good. I don't even,
I can't even explain it.
It's just like, just watch it.
- [Joey] All right. All right.
- And, you'll see it like-
- What's the channel called?
- Arcade Craniacs.
- Yeah. And like, they just do a thing
where it's like, "Oh,
I went to get the BTS meal
and then at 3:00 AM
and then the BTS Jimin
was delivered to my door
or something.
And he like pronounced the
name horribly or something.
- That's already funny.
- And then he's like, what is this?
And he drinks the Sprite.
And he's like, it's BTS sweat.
I know I was at the concert,
and it tastes like their sweat.
And it's just like, what is this?
- I need to watch this now.
- It's insane.
Like, and it's so popular
right now on YouTube,
but it's so fun.
- What's going on with YouTube recently?
- It's just so obscure now and weird.
It's so good though. I
love where it's going.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It's getting so meta, like everything is
so meta right now.
I love it.
It's so funny.
If you haven't checked
it out, I kind of think
you have to watch a lot of YouTube
to enjoy it because it's
a parody on shit YouTube
that adults wouldn't watch,
but you would only know
if you watch videos
that roasted the kid's content anyway.
- Or you seen the memes of it.
- It requires like four
layers of YouTube knowledge
to enjoy it, but if you
watch a shit ton of YouTube,
you might enjoy it.
- [Joey] Okay. Okay.
- So, check it out. It's
a fever dream anyway.
It's very funny.
- All of what we've discussed right now
has just been a fever dream to me.
- We talk a lot about YouTube,
but it's just because we live it.
We watch it so much. It's so
relevant to everything we do.
- When you show me Dhar Mann,
I ended up staying up like drunk
till 4:00 AM watching his videos
just being like, "Wow, what is going on?"
- Why did you watch them?
- I don't know.
- Where was my invite?
That sounds like an amazing time.
- But, you were away.
- Yeah. You were away.
- Damn it.
- It would have to get
a little celebration
to open this office.
And then we went back and I was like,
"Let me show Dhar Mann.
- I just like my, my drunk 4:00 AM mind
just like could not comprehend
what I was watching.
Cause it was like, it
was a fever dream for me.
- Yeah.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Watch one Dhar Mann video,
'cause I can't, it's so hard to explain
what makes it weird.
- I'll give you a quick
run-through of Dhar Mann video
right now.
I'll do one it's like, all right.
"Hi. I am cheating wife."
"Hi, I am husband with failing business."
"Oh, okay.
Damn, you're so gross poor husband.
Get away from me.
I'm going to cheat on you with someone."
She cheats, and then
"Wow. My business is now succeeding."
Cheating wife wants to come
back and sleep with him again,
but he's like, "No, no.
I'm successful now and
happy in a relationship.
Moral of the story,
don't cheat on your husband
who is working hard and
being nice. That's it.
- Like what? It's just-
- And then everyone claps.
- That's not even deep.
It's just common sense.
- It's like, it's just, yeah.
Watch it. It's funny.
It's pretty funny.
- Oh my God.
- I mean, I saw one about like-
- Don't watch it alone.
Get, get a bunch of your friends,
have a few beers and then
enjoy the nature of it.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- It's just so good.
- I think I saw one that was like against
someone being racist towards an Asian dad,
trying to open a nail salon
or something like that.
- Right.
- And I think it was more of
the story is don't be racist.
And I was just like, great.
- I liked the idea that somebody out there
who is a susceptible to a video,
changing their whole view on racism
that they just watched
this and they're like,
"Shit, I've been racist this whole time.
I can't believe this." You know?
- I should go and apologize
to the two Asians I know in my life.
- And it's like, it's fine.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But it's like, you're out
here hustling, and I get it.
You know, it, that's easy
to make money off of do it.
Fuck it.
But, it's not going to
change anyone's mind.
- I mean, you know, I
appreciate the sentiment,
because obviously, you know,
racism is bad, you know,
in case you didn't know.
- If you didn't know, you
should watch a YouTube
of Dhar Mann.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. But I was racist before Dhar Mann.
Like every white man, I was racist.
- I was going to cheat on my boyfriend
that was trying hard to
succeed in his business
until I saw-
- But then I opened a fortune cookie.
- Or a Dhar Mann video.
- It's literally the
fortune cookies of YouTube.
- I was a gold digger
before I met Dhar Mann.
Now, I'm not longer a gold digger,
and I appreciate everything in life.
- Yeah.
Speaking about like the reason
why you weren't there
to share our Dhar Mann watch sesh Joey,
so I heard you went to Nintendo world.
- Oh shit.
Yeah you did.
- What? How did you know?
Is it possibly the Nintendo
World shirt I'm wearing?
- Yeah. You look like
a fucking staff member.
Can I help you? Can I-
- Dude, Okay.
- I forgot that you were there.
- Can I just say the Nintendo
World staff like uniforms?
- Yeah.
- They're not uniforms. That's drip.
Like it'll literally, it
literally looks so fucking cool.
I was like, I want that for merch.
Fuck these other, even
though I bought this,
fuck these other shirts.
It's like, I want what they're wearing.
- Fuck you, but I'm going to buy it.
- So, Aki and I went to USJ,
Universal Studios Japan,
and there's Nintendo World
there for our anniversary.
- [Connor] Very cool.
And I'd never been to USJ before.
In fact, I very much
despise amusement parks.
- Joey doesn't like amusement parks.
- I don't like amusement parks.
- I like thrill ride amusement parks.
- I like roller coasters.
- I'm the complete opposite.
I hate roller coasters.
- What? Why?
Why do you hate fun?
What's wrong with you?
And I think that's why I
don't like amusement parks
because a lot of amusement
parks are very focused on
like roller coasters
and like thrill rides.
- That's the best part.
- That's literally the best part.
- That's literally the reason-
- What do you hate about them?
Why do you hate fun?
- I don't hate fun,
because they're not fun.
- Oh, they're not fun?
- I don't think roller
coasters are fun at all.
- What?
- Are you scared of them?
- Yes.
- Oh, okay.
- I'm A, I'm scared of
them, but also B I'm like,
why do I have to wait
in line for two hours
to enjoy a ride that lasts five minutes?
- It's an experience you'll never get.
- No, it's an experience I can get.
In fact, it's an experience
I don't want to get.
- I think it's amazing.
- Well, I will fully buy the fact
that I am very much a pussy
when it comes to roller coasters.
- Your words, not mine.
- But, it's fine. I will live with that.
But so we went to Nintendo World
because it opened up in what was it
like February of this year?
- Yeah.
- It was a couple of months ago,
but obviously it was
fucked for a little bit
because of like-
- Because of "finna
open during a pandemic."
- Yeah. Yeah.
It was like, I'm going
to open during pandemic.
And then like no one came over.
So it was fucked for a few months,
but I think like a month or two ago
they like reopened to the public.
So we were like, "Fuck it. Let's go.
Like we couldn't go during
the press event. Let's go."
I'm an Nintendo boy.
I'm a gamer boy.
- I like Nintendo.
- You're gamer girl.
I'm a gamer boy.
- I've played a video game before.
- Yeah. I know Mario.
So we went dead ass,
was probably the most fun I've ever had
in an amusement park.
- Really?
- It was so fun.
So first of all, they
absolutely nailed the aesthetic.
- Okay.
- I've never, like people talk about-
- It did.
That was probably the thing
that it looked amazing.
- It looks amazing like
in the promotional videos.
It looks a hundred times more impressive
when you're there in real life.
- Wow.
- Was it sunny when you went?
- It wasn't.
We were kind of in the
middle of a typhoon.
- Did it still look good?
- It still looked amazing.
- Because all the
promotional pictures are like
in like the best lighting in existence.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah. Yeah.
- And I bet it would look and
feel amazing in the clouds.
'Cause that's what it's like in the game.
If it was pouring it down, you'd be like-
- Okay. I think the
weather was on our side
because the weather like subsided
like kind of halfway through the day.
- Okay. Okay.
- Right.
- But when we were there, it
was like pouring quite a bit.
But even in the rain, like I was like,
I thought they had just
oversaturated the trailer footage.
So it looked more impressive. I was like,
"Oh, they didn't over
saturate this at all.
They didn't color correct this at all.
This looks just as good
as in the trailer footage.
- Okay.
- And it's really impressive
because the scale of it
is so massive looking.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Like, because like you see like
the little like kind of mounds in
like the background and you think,
oh, that must be like really tiny.
They're fucking huge.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- They're like buildings
that you can like walk into.
- I-
- And like-
- Go on.
- Oh no, I was just going to say like,
I think the one thing that
I really enjoyed about it
is the fact that,
I mean, there's only
like two rides, three.
- That's. That's what I
was kind of like sad about.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Is that there was only two rides
and one of them was like a
car that takes you around.
- [Joey] Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
- And I was like, wow,
there is put all of the budget
into the set design, huh?
- Yeah. If you're into
like amusement parks
because of like roller
coasters and stuff like that,
I don't think that's
really the place for you.
Luckily, it's in USJ, so there's plenty
of roller coasters in USJ, but like-
- It'd be perfect for you though, right?
- Perfect for me.
- That's probably why
you enjoyed it so much.
I mean, I'm a fucking Nintendo
boy through and through.
- Yeah.
- And there were no real like
roller coasters type of thing,
but I think the thing
that impressed me the most
is the fact that you can
buy these like kind of,
I don't even know what they are.
They're like these electronic
watches essentially
that you can wrap around
and it essentially connects
to the entirety of Nintendo World
and makes the entire park interactive.
- Wait, how big is the park?
- Damn.
- Yeah.
- Okay. How big is the park?
- I want to say.
- How long can you see everything in?
Like an hour?
- Oh yeah. Easily in an hour.
- Okay.
- See the thing is even within,
even though the space isn't big
it's so jam packed with
shit that you can do.
Like literally there isn't a
single piece of wasted space.
- Right.
- Like this was engineered
to shit where it's like,
we got to feel every little space
up with something to do.
- [Connor] Yeah. Yeah.
And like, I feel like the electronic bands
that you have to buy it
like 3000 yen or something.
- Like 30 bucks.
- It was like 30 bucks.
but I think if you don't buy that,
you're probably missing out
on it about 70% of the park.
- What does it allow
you to do with the band?
- Okay, so the bands,
what they do is there are like,
so there's an app that
connects to the band
and that app, when you look at it.
- Oh, so you have to download the app?
- Yeah. So you download the app.
- Oh God, that's so annoying.
- Yeah. I mean, it's
a little bit annoying.
I guess if you're a tourist though,
if you're a tourist watch out for that,
maybe pre-download the app.
- Honestly, he was showing
me the app earlier.
It fucking looks incredible.
- I can show you to you.
So yeah.
You download the app
and then you go to the
Super Nintendo World
and then it loads up essentially.
- Oh. Okay.
- And then, you get a,
so basically there are these like stamps
that you can get for achievements
that you unlock by interacting
in Super Nintendo Wall.
- So, you're literally just
playing achievement hunter
with this theme park.
- I'm literally getting X-Box achievements
except instead of X-Box, they're Nintendo.
- Bruh. I'm gaming.
- Bruh, have your 100%ed Nintendo World?
- But like what's kind
of big brained about it.
- Dude, that looks so clean, honestly.
- It is clean, and like,
it does like an interactive map as well
that shows you like all of the locations
that you've been to.
- Oh. Okay. That, I'd fuck with that.
- Yeah. So, you know exactly
like which parts of the world
you haven't explored yet
or haven't actually interacted with.
- Oh, that's so good.
- And like, it's honestly like the band is
half the experience
because there's a couple
of rides in Nintendo World
that you can't even access,
if you don't have the band.
- That's kind of shitty though,
that you pay full price for the ticket
and then you gotta pay
30 bucks to get that.
- I thought so too, but
then the actual amount
of experience that you can get on top,
if you do pay for the 30 bucks is
I think it's completely worth it.
- I'll trust you.
And it's also good as well.
It's also good as well,
because there's so much,
it adds replay value
to actually going back
and like doing achievements
and like getting the best scores
and all that kind of stuff.
And like, if you go around
with like a bunch of friends.
- Right.
- Like, I went around with Aki,
and we were like trying to
fucking like one up each other
in terms of like achievements
and all of that kind of stuff
and like that is half the fun.
- Trash Taste special.
I'm just kidding.
- Dude, USA hit us up.
- I just realized that
Nintendo really just added
micro transactions to a bunch
of real life theme parks.
- They really did.
But like, I dunno, I thought
it was fucking big brained.
Like you can eat if you're, especially,
if you like love anything Nintendo-
- [Connor] I do.
- And, you're like fully ready
to like immerse yourself
in the actual park.
- Well, it's like Marioland. Right?
Is it?
- Yeah.
- Then if you're fully
ready to immerse yourself
in the land, like completely,
and just forget about the fact that like,
you know, this is essentially
one big micro transaction.
If you live the dream,
if you live the dream like
you do at any amusement park,
it is the most fun.
- So, how long did you spend in there?
- We spent about like five
or six hours in there,
but I could easily spend
a whole day in there.
Well like, we spent about
like maybe three quarters
of the day there,
because I wanted to like go around
to the other parts of USJ,
'cause I'd never been before.
So we went to like Harry Potter World
and like Jurassic Park World,
and all that kind of stuff.
That's there as well.
And that's the good thing, right?
Is that like, you know,
you can spend like a decent
amount of time there,
but if you get bored, just pop on over
to Harry Potter World
which is like literally
two minute walk from
Nintendo World, right?
But yeah, it was super fucking fun.
- I mean, I want to go at some point.
I haven't been in a rush to go.
'Cause I know that eventually
when people come to visit,
they're going to be like,
I want to go there.
- [Joey] Oh yeah.
- And, I'll be like,
"All right, let's go."
- [Joey] Yeah, definitely.
- I don't want to go that like five times
and have to take someone.
All right, let's go again.
- How were the crowds there?
- There crowds, well, it
was like decently crowded.
I think right now USJs really banking
off Nintendo World,
because I think the majority of the park
was at Nintendo World.
- Yeah. That's right.
- I mean, it is the newest thing
and like they're shilling the
fuck out of Nintendo stuff,
even outside of Nintendo World.
But I mean, when I went there,
it totally made sense as
to why that was the case.
'Cause it was, I was like,
damn this is like
completely different level
of upgrade to like any
other world out there.
- I want to go. I want to go.
- It's insane.
- I want to go as well, and I want to go
before the country fully opens up,
and then you get like the rush.
- Oh, you know it's going to
be hell when there's tourists.
- Yeah, Dude.
Tourists are going to be flooding.
- You probably enjoyed it
'Cause there was no one there.
Because like, imagine it.
You're at Nintendo World.
You're like, "Whoa,
what secrets can I see?"
And then, there's a line
for like every single thing.
And every single thing you've
got a bump or you use the-
- Yeah. We only had to
wait like max 15 minutes
for each ride.
- Which is very good
for an amusement park.
- Which is really good for USJ.
- Because, as we know
the worst thing about
amusement park are the
crowds and the lines, right?
- Because like, I think they also like.
- I like a good cue.
I like a good wait.
- Yeah. I don't.
- That's the British
coming out in you man.
- It is. I like a good cue.
I don't mind waiting.
- Because I think they also structured it
so that they were like anticipating
the massive amount of lines.
'Cause like the VR
Mario Kart, for example,
which is easily the best
ride that they have there.
- I did VR, Mario Kart with
you in Ikebukuro, right?
- At VR park, right?
- Is it the same thing?
- Completely different.
- Oh really.
- Yeah.
So, VR Mario Kart in VR park in Ikebukuro,
used to be in Shinjuku was like,
you're in like a still cart
and you have the VR goggles on
and then you have like the glove on
that you can use to grab items and stuff.
- Yeah, but the car had hydraulics in it.
So you would like when
you did forward it turned.
- Yeah. But this time around
in the Nintendo World,
the car itself is also moving.
So it's like moving on a rail.
- And then when you move it does it move?
- And when you move it it moves
and you have the VR goggles
on so that everything
around you now is basically a hologram.
- So, it's just VR go-kart?
- VR go-karting essentially.
- That sounds fun. I'm down.
- It's a hectic dude.
- I'm down.
- It's super fucking hectic.
But like that, obviously that one
I think is going to be the most popular,
but I think they perfectly
planned for it as well,
because from the entrance of the,
you have to enter Bowser's
Castle to get to it.
So, like the front of it
looks like Bowser's Castle
and like the interior and
everything is completely,
perfectly modeled off the Bowser's Castle.
So you like go up the stairs,
and there's a giant Bowser statue
that you have to walk past.
And, that's all part of the line.
- [Connor] Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
- And, you walk past it and
it's like all the Mario Kart,
like trophies all
stacked up like in order.
- [Connor] That's cool.
And like they clearly anticipated
for there to be a lot of people.
So, they were like,
we got to make waiting
in line entertaining.
- I don't know.
That's what like Disney
already did so well.
You know, I don't really like Disney,
but the themeing was on point,
right?
- Yeah.
Disney's theming was on point,
but then Nintendo was like,
let me one up that.
Let me one up it.
- That's a lot easier, right?
When you have a smaller
contained land to work with.
- [Joey] Definitely. Yeah.
- So yeah, but I mean, I do want to go,
I will go at some point,
I don't know fucking when.
- The only thing that would one up that is
if they added other Nintendo franchises
and then kind of expand on it.
- [Connor] Like Zelda.
- Yeah.
- Because right now it's only
really the Mario universe.
If the added light Zelda stuff Kobe stuff.
- Yeah.
- Or, like any of that.
- I do wonder if this was like a thing
that Nintendo wanted to
do or Universal was like,
"Come on Nintendo, we've
got a little plot of land."
- I have a feeling.
This is kind of like a
trial run for Nintendo.
- [Connor] That's what I thought.
- Where they were like,
if we opened up like a fully dedicated,
Nintendo World where there was like
different worlds for different franchises,
we don't want it to completely fuck up.
So let's just like borrow USJ for a second
and be like, "Can we like test it out
with like one small segment?"
- Yeah.
- And if it does, well then maybe
down the line we'll make like
an actual fully dedicated-
- Because, they could do a Nintendo World.
Like and actually have like, you know.
- Easy.
- They have enough franchises.
- With the amount of money
they made during the pandemic,
especially dude like-
- [Connor] Yeah.
- They could easily
open up their own world
if they wanted to.
- I mean, just think of all
the properties they have,
I'm like, all right,
well you've got like everything covered.
Like you can do any ride, any excuse.
- [Joey] Anything.
- You know what I mean?
Like everything's covered.
Why, haven't they done this already?
- Come on, Nintendo.
- I mean, Nintendo Land
from what the sounds of it
sounds really fucking good
and really fun already.
So, imagine that on like
a full-scale theme park
and maybe Joey will have an amusement park
that you actually enjoy.
- Yeah. Right. Cause I mean,
honestly like that was
probably the most fun
I've had in an amusement park ever.
- What food do they have there?
- Oh yeah. Som they have Toad's Cafeteria.
- Okay. And, what do they sell
in Toad's Cafeteria House?
- At Toad's Cafeteria, they sell,
the food that it was
actually pretty decent,
not the best themed food I've had.
'Cause I've been to like
a lot of like themed-
- Does it look like Mario characters?
- So one of them was this like tiramisu-
- I like tiramisu
that was shaped after
the like question block.
- [Connor] Oh. That sounds fun.
- Yeah. So, there's a tiramisu
shaped like question block.
There's also like a mushroom soup,
but like the container is
actually like the red mushroom.
- [Connor] Oh. Okay.
- So you like open up the red mushroom cap
and like there's mushroom
soup on the inside.
- I like that.
- It was pretty cute.
- I like it when the thing is like
the design of the character
or whatever they're trying to do.
It's not intrusive to
the flavor of the food.
- [Joey] Right.
It really me off when they
do that shit at Disneyland.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Or, when they like make
into like smiley faces
with my food and I'm like, listen,
I don't care about my
food being a smiley face.
Don't fucking do that.
I don't want to feel like I'm two.
I don't give a shit at your theming.
I don't want you to draw a
smiley thing on my steak.
It's a fucking steak.
- I mean, obviously I feel obviously
like Nintendo wall was definitely
aimed more towards like younger children.
- No. It's geared towards me.
I'm adult. I don't like it.
Fuck children.
- Yeah, but I feel like
they added so many elements
that like adults could also easily enjoy.
- Right.
- I mean, I fucking enjoyed it.
- My mom would never
buy me the food anyway,
when I was a kid.
So, it didn't matter.
She'd bring the food.
She's like, "You're not
having a theme park.
It's ridiculously
expensive, Connor. No way."
- It was a bit expensive. But you know,
as a first time experience,
I think we had to try it.
It was, again-
- It's like cinema popcorn, right?
- Wasn't the best experience
I've had at a themed
like cafe or anything, but pretty decent.
- Yeah. I don't know if it's still there,
but in the UK and like the
best, my favorite theme park,
they had the Alton Towers. Great one.
They had a restaurant that
was like, I don't know,
eight dollars all you can eat pizza.
- [Garnt] Oh shit.
- And I was like, "Yo, I'm like, yo,
let's go to the theme park."
"What, for the rides?"
- No.
- For the pizza bro.
- For the all you can eat pizza.
- Fuck yeah, dude.
- And it was great, 'cause you know,
you could vomit all off on the ride.
- Meanwhile, you go to Disneyland.
It's like, "Would you
like a slice of pizza?
Eight dollars, please?
- That's the thing, man.
I didn't think I would
appreciate it that much
until I was given all you can eat pizza
for like eight bucks.
And I was like, it wasn't great pizza,
but it was all you could eat
- [Joey] Yeah, exactly.
- I mean, it doesn't matter.
- [Joey] That's what counts. Yeah.
- On my life, I was like
this is the best theme park.
Fuck the rides.
Fuck the theming.
All you can eat pizza.
- I mean sure.
- If you put that at a theme park,
it automatically goes up a star rating.
- That just becomes
the best establishment.
- You got to Mario World, they're like
unlimited tiramisu,
just normal tiramisu, we
just got it from somewhere.
I'm like, "Okay shit.
Okay. Now we're playing?
Okay fine."
- Yeah fuck yeah.
- Just give me food.
- Just play the Mario
theme in the background
and I'll feel like it's themed.
- There's just something so nice
when you go to a theme park
and for one minute, they're
not trying to rip you off.
- Yeah.
- I feel the only thing
about Nintendo World
that I was like, "Whoa,
that's a bit weird,"
was toad speaking Japanese.
- Oh, really?
- What does that sound like?
(Connor squawks)
- Because, when you go
into Toads' Cafeteria,
there's like, on like a projection screen,
there's like Toad, like in the kitchen,
like preparing food and stuff
and he like notices you coming in.
And, he's like, "Oh, hey," kind of thing,
but in Japanese and I'm just like,
"Oh, that's, that's weird. Don't talk."
- Yeah. In Japanese games,
they use the English for the,
well, it's bad English but they record it.
- Yeah, but they use
like that (Joey squawks)
type of voice.
But then at the theme park,
they can't get away with just-
- Konichiwa.
- He's just like, "Yeah, Konichiwa,"
And I'm just like, "Oh, that's weird.
Just go (Joey squawks)
and then just be with it.
(Connor squawks)
- Yeah. It's really fucking bizarre.
- (Connor squawks) Eat
my fucking head. Eat me.
Drink out of my head please.
My head is your communion.
What the fuck Toad?
- Yeah. That was the only
part where was like, hmm.
Because like the same thing
happened in Harry Potter World.
'Cause we went to like, one of the,
one of the rides of Harry Potter world is
that you go into the Hogwarts
and it's like a kind of
4D interactive, like,
it feels like you're on a
broom and going through.
- Yeah.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Harry Potter and stuff like that.
And it's a really
fucking cool and intense.
- Yeah.
- Only thing that threw me off is
Daniel Radcliffe, speaking Japanese.
- Are you saying
Radcliffe speaks Japenese?
- Everyone was speaking Japanese.
- Does he have like a
British Japanese accent?
- No, it was just literally just like
they just grabbed a random
like anime voice actor.
And then I was like,
"Yeah, (foreign language),"
I was just like, "Oh, this is weird."
Daniel, what happened to you bro?
- It's like anime double.
- What was the best
line that he boiped out?
- The best line?
He was just like, when you are,
there's a scene where you like go like
fight through all the dementors
and he's I think in the English version,
you can actually see
Daniel Radcliffe mouthing,
being like, "Wow, that was
a close one. Wasn't it?"
Or, something like that.
But, in the Japanese one, he
was like, (foreign language)
I was like "Oh, Daniel, why?"
Why would they massacre my boy like that?
- Did they say the English spells?
- What do you mean?
Oh, yeah. Yeah.
It's the English spells,
but said in Japanese.
- Oh, what is it the ah?
- So, it's like in Castle Carna.
- Yeah, yeah.
So, it's not like, Wingardian Leviosah.
It's like Wingardian Leviosah.
- I don't know why that's so funny.
- Yeah.
- Foreign people trying to speak English.
Very funny.
- [Joey] I know. I know.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Yeah, but overall Nintendo was-
- Out of 10?
- Like solid nine, I reckon.
- Nine out of 10.
Really makes you feel like Mario.
- How much was that T-shirt?
I must know.
- How much was this one?
- [Connor] Yeah.
- This one was a 3,500 yen.
- I guess that's not too bad.
I was expecting you to be like $50.
I was like-
- I mean, there were like
$50 ones as well. Yeah.
- Really?
What were they?
Like, they better be like designer Gucci.
- Okay, one of them, I actually bought it
because it looked really cool.
'Cause it was at the,
it was next to the Bowser's Castle
and there was like a,
they themed the much store
next to the VR Mario Kart theme
as like in looking like the inside
of like a Mario Kart garage.
So they had like all of the,
there was one shirt that I bought
that had like, you know,
like in a lot of like a car racing,
like jackets that had like
all the patches of like
all the sponsors?
- Oh, that sounds cool.
- But it was a shirt
and all the patches were
like Mario themed.
- [Connor] Mm-hmm (affirmative).
- So like that was really cool.
And I was like, "Ooh, 55 bucks?
Fuck it. I'll take it."
- I would.
- Yeah. Sometimes for me it's like,
it's not about the price.
It's like, does it look cool?
And is it thing that I can only get here?
I'll probably fucking get it.
- Man, 12 year old would-
- That's why they can
hike up the price. Right?
- Exactly.
- Exclusivity.
- And, I'm like "Take my money, Nintendo.
You been taking my money for 26 years now.
I'm not going to be mad."
- What did you think is
the best part of the park
that you enjoyed?
- I think again,
it's the fact that like
buying like the electronic
bracelet and the-
- The micro transaction.
- Yeah, it's legit the fact that they made
literally every single aspect of the park
interactive in some way.
- I can't wait for it.
- Because like there's
like all these like question blocks
that are just randomly lying around,
and you can punch it and it
makes like the coin sound
and then the coins get
added to your bracelet.
- Yeah. It's just, imagine you rock up
with a family of six
and then they're like,
"Yeah, you have to pay
a yeah, an extra 180?"
"What, what?"
It'd be so sad though.
I wish they would do
include it in the ticket.
Or, I'm sure, maybe you can,
can you buy a tickete what?
Can you buy a ticket that includes it?
- You can buy it with the ticket. Yeah.
- That'd be cool.
- But like, we didn't know about it.
So we were just like,
"Oh. This is an option."
- Download the app before
you go as well, I guess.
- Can't wait for the Nintendo
World speed runners to go.
- We need a Nintendo World any percent.
- Nintendo World any percent.
And, I'll fucking do that.
- I'm going to try and go
for the record if I go.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And, don't go.
- Yeah.
- Alright, well I guess
that's it for today.
I don't really have
anything else to talk about.
- We can talk about
one other thing though.
- What?
- Our patrons.
- Our beautiful patrons.
- [Garnt] Yes. Of course.
- Hell yeah.
- Going out to was it
Garnt Gaylord or something
was one of the names?
- Grant Gaylord.
- Exuse me Grant Gaylord. Sorry.
- I wonder if he's on the list?
- I think he might be.
- Yeah. Somewhere here, maybe.
- The most epic name of all time.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- But thank you to the patrons
for making it possible.
And again for funding this
brand new set. Wonderful.
- Yeah.
We love how you guys are loving it
because we enjoy it and we're
not going to change, so.
- Yes.
- Yeah. Boo hoo.
- Why be mean to our viewers Joey?
- I'm not being mean. I'm not.
But yeah, if you guys want to support us,
then go to our Patreon,
atrion.com/trashtaste.
Also follow us on Twitter,
send us your memes on the sub Reddit.
And if you added our faces
go the stores on Spotify.
- And hopefully you enjoyed this time.
The episode of Trash Tastes,
where we talk about current topics,
which should have just happened last week.
Enjoy it.
'Cause this is going to be the last time
it happens for a while.
We are looking to build
up our reserve again.
- A diamond hand to you.
A diamond hand's will trash this episode.
We're holding.
- Yeah, I guess that's everything right?
- Bye.
- We'll see you guys next time. Bye.
(chill ambience music)